today's guest um
[Music]
jeepers uh
i
you know i've never had an interview
where it was not a conversation really
so i think it's you know
and i'm saying this now because i i it
was hard to get a word in um
[Music]
i am grateful for this man's time
but i was happy when it ended uh
this man is a former governor
of minnesota
um he is a unique man
and he will tell you all about it
i am very grateful for his time
and i mean that and i learned a lot that
i can do a better job as an interviewer
i think for sure i did learn that um
but he makes some really interesting
points and he does talk about some
things that i'm really excited to uh
that i was grateful to get to speak for
to hear him speak on
i'm not trying to rinse the dude
but
i didn't get a chance to say anything so
i felt like at the very least i deserved
that uh i'm very happy to have today's
guest mr jesse ventura
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
do you ever see these ads on tv now
where
where they got the big lawsuit against
3m
because the hearing devices for the
military and combat apparently were
defective i haven't seen them well they
got ads on tv all the time
it's a class-action lawyer right you see
those lawsuits yeah that if you're deaf
and you served in the military blah blah
blah blah blah blah you had 3m made
these things you stick in your ears i
guess that are supposed to save your
hearing and what happened well no and
they didn't work function right so now
there's a lawsuit on it which is all
fine and dandy but i sit back and go
well gee
what about us vietnam guys that nobody
gave us nothing for our ears
we're all deaf today yeah it and and in
our in in my and what it tells me is
this
how different the combat was in the
middle east and vietnam
because in vietnam you couldn't wear
earplugs you relied on your ears wow
you're in the jungle you gotta listen
you gotta hear
you you hear a twig snap
it could be your life yes yeah and you
have to hear it right you know but in
this urban fighting apparently you can
put in earplugs and blast each other
because you're in the city right
or the desert so it's just interesting
how like through bat as time
yeah you can't even listen to pearl jam
enjoyably you know where yeah oh no but
there's better than pearl jam
i found a new young rock band that has
given me
my youth again
what is that it's a group i don't know
if you guys know i'm greta van fleet oh
yeah oh my god yeah i i i was a huge led
zeppelin fan
and bonham died and the rift between
plant and paige they're never gonna get
together they're never gonna play again
and my heart ached
because i thought i'm gonna go to my
grave and never hear
any more led zeppelin yeah they're gone
yeah my son comes over the other day
he says hey dad he said
you liked zap didn't you i said hell
yeah psalm in 72 and 75.
and he said listen to this
and he put on a song
and i sat listening to it and i looked
at him i said
what did jimmy page release from
the archives i've never heard this
zeppelin song before well that much he
goes they're not that isn't led zeppelin
i go what
and he said that's a dog a band called
greta van fleet out of michigan wow then
he pulls up
on on
his phone
an interview with robert plant
and robert plant talks about him
he talks about the greater the van fleet
and robert plant laughingly goes
somewhere i've heard that voice before
and he goes i'm jealous
wow because he said they're young and
i'm not yeah
well youth becomes that great i think
this guy
he's not quite totally robert plant
because he's a little rough on the edges
with the little getty lee throwed in
from rush yeah yeah i can see he's got a
little not a feminine side but a little
bit more of that the plant had that yeah
yeah very much at a feminine side to his
voice he'd sing those slow bluesy songs
drive my wife crazy yeah
and to me
i don't care what anybody says the best
zeppelin album is the first yeah
is that when you went and saw him was
around that time oh no i saw him in 72
uh
fourth had already been out because they
did stairway that night where'd you go
see them san diego who'd you go with do
you remember guys in the navy yeah i was
in the navy i was sitting back from my
first tour after vietnam wow and now we
went south zeppelin and uh in fact are
we running yes sir oh we're on can you
hear us okay yeah we're wrong
oh no that's fine then we're on and
rolling then let's talk or we'll talk to
rock and roll though yeah let's talk
about it no i'm just curious yeah no
we're we're where i was that weekend uh
that was the toughest rock and roll
weekend of my life was led zeppelin
i was uh it was 72 so i was about 21 i
guess 21 years old maybe 20.
and zeppelin was friday night
and led zepp played with no warm-up band
they would come out at eight o'clock and
they would finish at 11 15. three hours
and 15 minutes of led zeppelin and the
only break they ever took
was during moby dick when john bonham
would do about a 15-minute drum solo
then the other three would walk off
drink their water whatever they were
going to do
have a cigarette or whatever they were
going to do and then come back out and
at the end of bonham's drum solo and
then they'd finish up well i saw
zeppelin
on friday night
which was rugged
and we had to come back saturday and
then face jethro tull wow because that
was the weekend zeppelin friday jethro
tall saturday and were you guys partying
before like were people partying pretty
hard well
well no no in those days
open seating
oh no oh geez i used to bodyguard the
bands when there was still open seating
craziness that open seating ended in
cleveland i think or somewhere
at a who concert
where the people trampled to death three
or four people
died wow and that's when the authorities
came in like they always will as soon as
people are dying
they're gonna come in and say wait a
minute you're having fun but people are
dying yeah yeah
so no and then they then they put on you
that you had to have tickets just to be
on the main floor and they started
having security to where but in the
early days oh
you just packed in when i did the stones
here yeah right
they got the boards the hockey boards we
would line up in the pit before the
stone and you know stones come out word
of security down in the pit down there
and they would tell us over the
walkie-talkies okay we're opening the
doors
you would literally feel the ground
start shaking wow
like running of the bulls
and a slow roar would start and then
you'd look up and the doors had opened
and these guys would be running and
literally diving
down the stairs to get to the floor to
be first in the front row
and do you feel like you're playing
defense at that point
you got the barricades up right they can
only come up to the barricade the hockey
boards wow you know but they're they
pack in there
so tight
this is before they had when they had
open seating so tight
that you'd see during a concert people
raising their arms up down front waving
them just to breathe oh no no no they
can't bring them down wow
they raised them up
to get space and air
and then the wedge wedges them in so
much they can't bring their arms down so
they have to stand the rest of the show
with their arms in the air or setting
them on somebody else's shoulders
or whatever i had a i
had a little girl and i was in peak
wrestling because i had some knee
surgery and i was at the prime of my
wrestling when i was doing this
and uh
uh so i i i had a i was
265 pounds
you know i was it could lift well on the
600 you know
i mean i was i was a bruiser
265 pounds and had a little girl down
front that wanted to get out
she couldn't take it no more and what we
do to people like that we'd pull them
out and then shut them down they didn't
get kicked out we just let them in the
back okay now the people who cause
trouble different story yeah but like
this young girl she was she was crying
claustrophobic couldn't take it no more
i had to stand on the boards get under
her armpits now i can dead lift over 600
pounds it was like pulling a cork out of
a bottle
because of the compression i had
everything i could do i broke into a
sweat wow and finally i got her out and
we got her town and she thanked me and
we sent her down the line then on the
flip side i had some bozo start punching
somebody ah
and his back was to me and he had long
hair
i got up on the boards got a hold of his
hair wound it into my hands and removed
him by the hair oh damn you can imagine
what that felt like well he hits the
deck jumps up gonna fight me and i just
looked at him and i said think again
and he opened his hands up and backed up
and i said
get the f out of here and we shuttle and
he went out the door yeah you know he
didn't get let back in
he went out the back door do you miss i
got to i got to introduce the stones did
you really yeah because one night uh
during this it was 78 or 81 i think
because
you're a bouncer you're basically
security security but you're also
wrestling at this point oh yeah but you
wrestle unprofessionally you're
wrestling like okay
so people know who you are too sometimes
oh yeah gave me stuff to brag about on
tv yeah you know gave me stuff for
interviews oh
i they came out
levy was the promoter and he comes up to
me and i think it was 81
and he says to me we got no one to
introduce the stones he goes you want to
do it
i said hell yeah i'll do it
so but here's what's good they tell you
exactly what you're to say and you can't
vary from it you walk out under the
spotlight
the whole 19 000 people or whatever at
st paul civic center
and you simply walk up to the mic and
you go ladies and gentlemen
the world's greatest rock and roll band
the rolling stones and you walk off damn
does it feel pretty honorable i did get
a good payback because that night at the
end of the show as they left the stage
ronnie wood looked at me and said hey
jesse how'd we do yeah i said good woody
good
[Laughter]
as you um
i could tell you all sorts of rock and
roll stories really yeah from
i one time i got a sign jagger where i
just followed mick around so you're just
doing security for him yeah no no
i did security
the bands that would come to minnesota
okay i didn't travel with them okay we
would get them here okay and then we
would provide security and ensure they
got once they were in the building we
had them and we ensured they got in
their limos right then they're on their
own so we don't know or other wrestlers
other rep
do
a friend of mine i knew i'd had some
knee surgery and he said hey you want to
make 25 bucks a night and hear the best
rock and roll in town and i loved rock
and roll and you got the best seat in
the house and they pay you 25 bucks or
50 bucks i forget what it was you got
paid
for doing it i said sure i'll do it so i
just go over there and you just sit down
in the pit and nice did springsteen
foreigner marshall tucker grateful dad
did all of them all the greats from that
the grateful dead's easiest is it really
oh they're so good the dead heads yeah
they all know each other they travel
there's a group of fans that travel to
every dead country oh yeah they're all
doing grilled cheeses
yeah and they they talk to each other
bob we missed you in omaha well i
couldn't make omaha but i'll see you in
east lansing okay
they all know each other they don't even
rush the stage
the deadheads just dance around in the
aisles they're like hippies you know and
the dead goes off on their tangents
because no dead song's ever the same you
know they they take it any direction
yeah they get real whimsical oh yeah and
so that was the grateful dead they were
the easiest really off we left the front
yeah
these guys
they all know they're grateful dad
they're like friends yeah it's like
playing a concert in front of your
friends
you know
so uh yeah i bet if you're one of the if
you're one of them you're just seeing
the same people every day
i mean while they change a little bit
like bob couldn't make omaha right
but i think i was on lsd just because i
would see the same people in the crowd
every night i'd be like yeah so maybe
they thought that too i don't know
i did all the bands back then and and uh
it was a great experience was there a
point that you quit what did work just
get too busy oh no no i went back
wrestling you went back oh yeah no no no
that's right you can't you ain't gonna
survive doing what i was doing right
not in the lifestyle i preferred to live
yeah that was just busy work and fun
you know and and uh and it paid off
later because here's the story later
on 1998 i became the governor of
minnesota yeah i took office in 1999.
and uh 1999 was the rolling stones no
security tour
that's what it was called yeah they came
to minnesota in
february wow
i'm the governor now
and so as governor and here's what i did
i had never did a governor's
proclamation you know where the governor
proclaimed something yeah
so
being the outlaw i am and the governor
of belonging to neither political party
which gave me great freedom in many ways
uh my first thing as governor i declared
it the day that the stones played here
and the no security tour in 99 i
declared it rolling stones day in
minnesota
now it went to the
secretary of state because they have to
sign off on it too right
and i won't say names but we have this
kind of tight-ass republican woman
from you know do i need to say more no
we could easily find that you can you
can figure it out right now
i picked up my phone in the governor's
office i called her up so i said
whatever her name was i just first name
i said
sign the proclamation
don't make me come down there
and i set the phone down
the proclamation was back in about five
minutes dude that's awesome
she signed off i said give me a break
yeah what are we doing and well the
great payoff came that night
because that night i was there to
when the stones were and they had been
greeted at the airport by the press and
they asked mick jagger how do you feel
the governor declared at rolling stones
day in minnesota and mick said we were
very honored they said no one's ever did
that for us before wow you know we've
never come to a state and had the state
declare it our day yeah
so they were very honored did they
remember you that you did security well
that's coming up okay so uh we come
there that night and i get my picture
taken with them and up comes my favorite
stone keith richards yeah and so
keith comes up to me that night and his
hair's all away
typical keith richards they had band on
he's got this hanging off here the hair
and that hanging off the air the hair
and he looks up at me
in typical keith richards style and he
goes uh
so you used to bodyguard us back in 78
and 81 huh you know somebody told him
that i'm sure
and i go yup
and he goes and now you're the governor
and i go yep
and in the great keith richards cockney
accent i'll remember it the rest of my
life
he looks at me and goes
great
[Laughter]
i'll never forget it
great
you know and just smiled at me and i
thought well if you get an effing great
from keith richards you've done
something right that's how i view it do
you feel
oh i i agree i mean do you feel that
uh so stuff like that that's kind of
feels like do you feel like that's
coincidence do you feel like there's a i
find it interesting when you're able to
live life long enough how things
intertwine a lot and how amazingly
something comes back like a helicopter
you launched 20 years ago comes and
lands on your palm like a butterfly now
like boomerang yes
that's a perfect analogy do you think
that there's any god in that or you just
think that that's just nature that's the
way i believe i believe like like uh uh
neil degrasse tyson says
it's chaos yeah
he said this there's no one in control
of space yeah neil said everything is
flying around out there there ain't
nothing in control or nothing it's chaos
and i my belief in life is this having i
didn't plan to be governor
i didn't sit back when i was 18 20 years
old and say you know i'm gonna take
political science someday i'm gonna run
for governor be mayor first i'm gonna be
a mayor first then i'm gonna be governor
i didn't plan nothing like that
sometimes i don't even plan to wrestle
yeah things just fell into place and i i
lived by a premise that i think i've
i've mentioned it
a quote from the great yogi berra the
baseball player i don't know how
familiar we are with yogi but yogi used
to say some great one-liners and yogi's
one great one-liner was if you come to
hawaii in the road take it
keep going no think come to a y in the
road take it
well that means you got to pick one way
or the other that's what he's telling
you right so i've come to wise in the
road
and i've taken them
and once i've picked out which
of the y
i'm going on i don't look back right and
i and i conquer whatever that y is
taking me to then when i achieve that
i look for the next y in the road wow
and then i do that because i've had so
many jobs now oh yeah it's bad i i sit
back and look at him go
how
you know i guess
when you look i get bored after about
four years really
and then i need the y in the road yeah
i need to go out and
because i mean i where do you think that
comes from justin not to interrupt you i
just you know i'm curious like it's a
certain wanderlust that i think you're
born with is it you think you've
inherited i've read two books on che
guevara right and one book was written
by a south american so you got a real
good
view of che it wasn't written by a
united states person with great bias
right you know you got it from a south
american which is argentina's where che
was from
and che had it
che couldn't stay somewhere i mean he
had he had it made in cuba right he was
like god in cuba yeah and he was
handsomer to infidel well and they put
him up he's he's there i've been to cuba
yes he's on he's on that building oh
they're libraries their libraries start
with books on che and phil there's no
history before them they had
they would stay did he they were heroes
shea didn't stay did he kind of heroes
no no
he needed something else
it's almost like that he couldn't stay
it's like brad pitt in that movie
there's a times come on certain jobs i
do
where i can't stay no more yeah
that i gotta i gotta go on i gotta move
i gotta get go keep going maybe
maybe i'm giving up the day that i say
okay this is it
right i'm not this is i'm on the final
why in the road
but i ain't there yet i don't think i'm
70 now wow but uh that's why i moved to
mexico 15 years ago i wouldn't even know
that oh yeah i've been living in mexico
for 15 years every winter i live an hour
from pavement an hour from electricity
and has that been do you feel like it's
been beneficial off the grid wow i who
do you take with you down there
i take my pickup truck my wife and my
dog
and was there a reason you guys chose
down that area was there no yeah just
kind of
like my life a why came in the road yeah
i took it no what happened on that deal
was i had just come out of office and i
needed a break of being governor
and i just inked a huge contract with
msnbc
right
you noticed i was never on i was going
to say i'd never seen any clips of this
yeah no because i was never on the
reason we'll get back but i'll cover
this because i've covered it before and
i like people to know by the way i'm
going to do a shameless plug here on
your thing please do i'm i'm now on
clubhouse okay
okay so people call the governor's
office okay so anybody that wants to
tune me in can go to clubhouse in the
governor's office okay and i'm on sunday
night at 7 00 central
and wednesday night at 7 central okay i
go on an hour each those nights so
anybody out there that does this
and wants to hear more from me that's
where they can do it there yeah
is there something interfering with your
happiness do you have you ever had
happiness
that's a question i've also often asked
myself do i ever have ever had happiness
and i don't know sometimes i have
moments of it flashes
but i've ever had a real soup of it i
don't know
is it possible for me
that's a question i have often times
better help
can help
if there are questions about your mental
and well-being your depression anxiety
you need answers better help
is committed to facilitating
great
therapeutic matches that make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need
you can zoom with them you can um rock
with them zoom with them rock them you
can do on the phone you can even text
them you know
if you if you having trouble getting
help in your area
don't give up on getting help visit
betterhelp.com theo that's b e t t e r h
e l p
dot com slash theo
this podcast is sponsored by better help
i've gotten better help and tpw
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
theo learning a new language have you
ever tried that have you ever tried to
learn a new language
were you in high school and you tried it
didn't happen did it are you spanish
well anything can happen
thanks to babel
the number one selling language learning
app
oh the whole process is addictively fun
become
the
the linguist you want you want to talk
to somebody who's russian learn how to
spanish
french
they got it all they teach bite-sized
language lessons for real-world use damn
you can use it at this it's static bugs
uh uh says the thunderbox
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you improve your
pronunciation
and
aksal oxon
right now when you purchase a three
month babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months free
that's six months
that's babel babbel.com
code theo
that's babb
el.com
code theo a three month bible
subscription get three months free
language for life
anyway getting back to uh what were we
talking about now well i guess
you know i mean there's different areas
that are like no no no you took so you
got to the end of your governorship or
yeah were you exhausted no yeah i i and
i just well i had signed with msnbc
well
i got paid for three years and did
nothing
and i got paid a lot of money why
because i opposed the invasion of iraq
they wouldn't put me on television
really nobody was allowed on tv who
opposed the invasion of iraq i'll give
you the example msnbc at that when i got
out of office
fox msnbc and cnn got in a bidding war
for me i was the voice of the
independent
voice of the independent don't belong to
either party yeah
msnbc one i signed a three-year contract
with them
and i'll just state this
it was a contract that a professional
sports athlete would get wow not not 100
million yeah but it was healthy yeah it
was
very nice
i'll say that and so i signed a
three-year contract with them
and we insisted that they were going to
do my show in minnesota
because i number one i didn't want to
leave here make it easy on yourself so
you were living and i had the power at
that time so i said no i want to do the
show in minnesota and here's what i sold
them on because all you people do is
cover the coasts yeah nobody gets a
midwestern perspective of nothing and
we're the heart of america amen
we're the heart of america amen you know
so uh they agreed so
go over to channel 2 here in the twin
cities i provided 30 jobs or something
because they had to hire all these
people to work on the show so i provide
all these jobs after i get out right and
one of the jobs was to my head of
communication when i was governor he now
stayed with me and was working on the
show with me so do you go to one day of
work at all no wait okay so so so so
we're very very easy
they send a producer out okay from the
base msnbc so he's producing the show
we're getting all set to go on the air
live audience now we're gonna have a
live audience because i play better yeah
in front of
live you know and it's everything's
ready to go and all of a sudden we get a
phone call
here's the phone call oh let me add
msnbc had just hired phil donahue
the king of daytime
he was now on at night he was their
highest rated show
phil likewise opposed the invasion of
iraq yeah and said it publicly
so had i
we get a phone call
john my subordinate at the right
communication
he got the call here's the call
um
this is so is it true governor ventura
doesn't support the invasion of iraq
john oh no he's vehemently opposed to it
he's a vietnam veteran he said this is
vietnam all over again this is crap this
is nation building is
they didn't attack us iraq didn't attack
us on 9 11. yeah why are we invading
iraq yeah a lot of you know and and so
then the next question
does connecticut know about this
well here's the tie-in
msnbc stood for
microsoft nbc
at that time okay it was a partnership
between microsoft and nbc
who owned nbc at that time espn general
electric oh really general electric is
one of the biggest war profiteers in the
world damn they are they are the
military industrial complex and part of
it because they have all those contracts
with them wow everything is built by ge
to go to war yeah a lot of it
right oh i'll probably have a job
one of their announcers on tv opposing a
war not a chance damn exactly so
that was that does connecticut know
about this was the second question
we respond or
john responded i don't know
pause
here's the big question is there any
chance he changes mind wow
john said i don't think so he said i've
seen the governor change his mind where
because he wasn't educated on something
well enough and when he got educated he
took a different viewpoint right but he
said this is war he's a veteran he's
opposed to it he's a vietnam veteran you
ain't going to change his mind guess
what i didn't go on the air and guess
what phil donahue got pulled damn
they pulled both of us have you ever
heard of a network pulling their highest
rated show no never
but they did because they wanted no
negative to invading iraq on the
mainstream media so that's how powerful
those tie-ins are between like these
companies and the corporations and the
mainstream media and the government yeah
and the government so do you feel
sometimes it used to feel like
one thing that's tougher as i've learned
more as i as i get older and just learn
more sometimes you're going to find out
you're going to learn even more
sometimes i don't want to how old are
you i'm 40 years old oh you got a lot of
learning left
you're just beginning to learn i want to
man
i just begin but i feel like all you've
done is cracked the door open a little
but do you ever think sometimes that
it's this almost a
more blissful value and not not like
they say knowledge is power and
sometimes it just almost hurts me
sometimes the more i learn stuff
sometimes it feels it makes me feel
debilitated sometimes
but you have to know you can't live a
life in my opinion you can't live a life
without truth
i finish every show i do i always say
and always remember people when the
government lies the truth becomes a
traitor
now think of that quote that's an
original from me i'm thinking about it
right government lies the truth becomes
a traitor in other words they'll take
the truth and put the truth in jail and
make it the enemy
wow and they'll make the truth the enemy
you see it all the time right now i feel
like we're
that's never seen more prevalent than
right now right yep
do you feel like um and yet i will back
there is good government right don't
think for a moment that i'm i'm not a
trumpy
i want you to know that right now
you know i don't even want to get into
my feelings on him yeah and as an
ex-military man right there's a lot of
impact there
to me january 6th was an attempted coup
d'etat really absolutely look at what
they're learning now yeah they had the
format all laid out
oh yeah it almost seemed like one of his
shady contractors could have set it up
hillary clinton lock her up yeah there's
the guy that belongs in jail right
donald trump he tried to overthrow our
country he defied the constitution
do you know i live by the constitution
right that's the document i live by if
you don't like it change it
but you got to have a set of rules yeah
those are the rules
he broke them yeah he broke the rules
yeah he should never be allowed to run
again yeah and in far as i'm concerned
he belongs in jail
because people died that day right on an
insurrection to overturn our government
right
it's that simple and i don't care how
these republicans want to butter the
bread
you're talking to the independent here
and you know what part angered me the
most
what is it when i saw a confederate flag
carried through my capitol yeah
what does that make you feel you know
what i call the republicans now the
taliban
they're the american taliban baby
and that's coming from jesse the body
the american taliban well look what
they're doing in texas yeah
what oh
where's women's rights yeah the taliban
have got them down there
you know they're taking away people's
right to vote
did you know it's easier to buy a gun in
texas than vote yeah that's insane
that's insane you want the definition of
insanity there's a good one right there
and now this latest thing what was the
latest thing that crazy governor oh
he's now over the governor
overruling
masked mandates yeah in other words no
one in texas can make you wear a mask
okay well what about this thing let me
ask you this do you feel like and by the
way i love the mask right you know why i
wrote an op-ed piece it gave me freedom
yeah i can go in the store now nobody
bothers me and if i keep my mouth shut
nobody does and i don't have to talk to
people that i probably didn't want to
talk to anyway yeah yeah
you're seeing little jessie the bodies
coming out oh yeah that's good that old
villain look i'm ready to get body
slammed well you know why the villain's
coming out i got people criticizing me
now saying i've sold out because i got
vaccinated
what a crock of crap
i sold out because i want to live and i
look at the statistics and when 99 of
the vaccine people live and only one
percent die i'm going on the 99 side
people but do you understand but jesse
why do you think do you want is it able
are you able to like have an idea of why
some people think i feel like the news
made things very confusing the news
started becoming like not information
and a lot of people got extremely scared
and didn't know who to believe anymore
well here you go you want the answer to
the news yeah jesse has it yeah i'd like
a you know i wouldn't mind a dose of it
man because that's where i feel like a
lot of bad information started downfall
of the news came with the show 60
minutes
now you guys are all gonna sit and go no
i lie i i i how could you 60 minutes
that's an award-winning investigative
reporting show which it is and it's a
great show
it was a great show still is probably a
but 60 minutes was the downfall of the
american media why is that when they
started editorializing it
but prior to 60 minutes
all the news lost money
and then they made up for it in the
entertainment division and that was a
standard rule
the news is to educate the news is to do
this the news don't make money it's to
inform
along came the show 60 minutes it shot
the number one
in the ratings the bean counter's eyes
got big and they went you mean we can
make money off the news yeah that's what
60 minutes caused
making profit off the news
then it became about ratings rather than
informing
now the news is nothing but
entertainment right
so it's there to get ratings points it's
there to make money for advertisers
where in the days of walter cronkite
back when i
was younger than you
the news lost money you want the show
that was so ahead of its time the movie
that it's scary today for me to watch it
watch the show network yeah with faye
dunaway uh
william holden i've seen that it's good
and peter finch won the academy award
for playing howard beale because he just
got so real okay and that's and it
changed everything
that's where it became entertainment
remember they brought faith done away in
from entertainment yes to get the rabies
the new producers this was done before
it ever happened to the news yeah they
call up to her desk
yeah
so that movie whoever wrote the script
or whatever
was was looking into the future and had
their thumb right on the button wow
because that's what our media or our
news has turned into the movie network
so then but it's all about ratings
points now guys it ain't about making
you smarter or giving you information
it's about titillate look looking right
now
what's the big news out there right now
another missing white girl yeah
now if that girl was black you think
they'd be all that front page
stories every night
if it was a lot of black people hiking
really though but maybe probably not
maybe not you know maybe not
black girls disappear every day yeah and
you don't see though
where they i saw every all people
disappear every day probably but why is
it that they pick out
the kids right there's a cute looking
little one
distress yeah yeah the cute little and
don't get me wrong it's a tragedy it's
horrifying
whatever happened to her don't get me
wrong on that no totally i'm the media's
coverage of it it's okay when i was
gonna do the show for msnbc everything
comes down from on high yeah they tell
you what they're like hannity and these
guys they get told what to talk about
totally yeah you know oh i bought them
you know what they sent me every day
lacey peterson what and i said
that's a tragedy but there's 10 000
murders a year why is this one
exceptional and why should people in
minnesota or in the east coast care
about a murder that took place out in
california yeah yes we feel sad lacey
was murdered
like i feel sad that anybody else gets
murdered but why would i on a national
tv show
give five minutes of the show's time
covering a murder that affects
that when you have ten thousand of them
a year yeah
so
but so okay with that said that's where
i feel like where do people go to get
good information and that becomes the
scary part that's how things a lot of
things become fragmented
remember when larry king died
oh yeah now larry king was an icon i got
to go on this show one time man it's
pretty cool oh yeah larry king an icon i
did a show a number of times i feel
fortunate larry king talked to everyone
yeah
well they did all these tributes to
larry
right which they should well deserved
but they left out the last five years of
larry's life
they stopped the tributes when he left
cnn
do you know where he went to oan right
to his oh he went to where i work
russian television america
oh really rt america larry king was
there
foreign was a podcast owned by larry i
worked for him oh interesting i did a
podcast called off the grid on aura
where i did it from mexico oh wow i come
into town once a week and they'd put me
up at the hotel i'd play two rounds of
golf and i'd do aura and go back to my
house it was great so they were warning
him whenever he went and did his own
thing larry worked for rt russian
television my aura thing i had a problem
with them in negotiations russian tv
came in and said we'll take you so i
went with rt america where larry was for
five years larry king worked at rt
america that is russian television
america and you know what he said
he said this is the most honest news
people are going to get
and this came from the icon larry king
who our mainstream media didn't want
that quote out there so they didn't
cover the last five years of larry's
life
they made larry retire after cnn larry
wasn't retired larry was on every week
like i am on rt america yeah and before
i signed with rt
they flew me and my wife to moscow
i went yes i went to their 10th
anniversary of rt yeah uh i met
gorbachev that night and uh putin was
the keynote speaker
wow and at the end of the night
vladimir putin the president of russia
walked over to me i didn't walk over to
him
he walked over to me did you stand up
right
absolutely he's the president i stood up
he offered his hand i shook his hand
putin looked at me and said thank you
governor
and i said you're welcome mr president
and then he said i want you to know i i
i will never interfere in your
television show you have complete
control and complete artistic freedom
and i said thank you mr president i
appreciate that and guess what i've been
there four years now and he's been a man
of his word have you yet he has never
interfered in my show nobody tells me
what i can say or can't say they don't
tell me what i can or can't talk about
now isn't it strange i'm banned
from tv in america wow
i'm banned and that's because of my
court case they all came into my court
case to have it overturned oh when you
uh the chris kyle mess oh yeah the lie
about me yeah yeah
lie yeah yeah well what people don't
know at the at the
two judges at the court of appeals broke
two of their own rules and sided with
the media and overturned my case
breaking their rules to do it so how do
we differ
and and in doing so
where can i go to work yeah these people
interfe i was you know they interfered
in my court case
so i have i can so i work for rt now and
it's they're the best do you know what
they did for me
[Music]
i started they were sending me to a
studio right
and misha my boss he goes uh you know
that's expensive and it's really out of
the way for you
he's a russian
he said do you have room in your house
i said sure i said i got a bedroom down
in my basement i kind of call it my
trophy room i keep all my
trophy paraphernalia down there in the
corner of the house nobody can see it
unless i take them down there he said
could we put a studio in there wow i
said sure all of a sudden amazon boxes
start arriving at my house
technicians come they took out all the
permits they wire me up
the cameras the lights i now do my show
for my basement that's awesome
i'm in minneapolis
they're in dc and my partner's in l.a
yeah and they have the capability now
that we can do a complete show and never
even be in the same city with each other
this is something it's an ideology it's
amazing
and so that's how i do my show i walk
downstairs
and uh and i'm happy to say my son is
home now he worked for rt for still
working for them and he came home and uh
he now
uses my studio to stay working with rt
wow and he's back home which makes his
mom and me very happy you're always
happy when the
the son comes back even when he's 41 or
42 now is that your only child no i have
a daughter oh yeah she lives here oh she
does yeah she's married and lives here
but my son's more of the
the he's more of his dad really
traveling oh yeah he hasn't lived here
for 20 years he graduated from high
school left wow he was sean penn's
assistant oh really he had that wander
thing in him huh oh yeah and he went
sean penn i remember the time he called
me says hey dad
i said yeah he says guess where i'm
going tonight i said where he says
uh he's over at i'm at the con film
festival we're having a party with the
victoria's secret models
and i said to him over the phone i said
well you ought to enjoy yourself
oh i used to masturbate to their
magazines man remember that magazine
came in the mail
those are the good old things oh yeah
well he calls me said oh yeah we're
going to a party tonight with the
victoria's secret models
that ought to be fun
no he he my son left at 20 yeah you know
and he too he was sean penn's assistant
for a while that he lived and worked in
la for 10 years and then an opportunity
opened up for him at rt america he was
on the ground floor he got into rt when
they were a few rooms on the floor now
they're two complete floors of a
building wow
does it feel is it strange that that
it's a russian company and that they're
making well they're technically not
they're an american company right i'm
just wondering is there any like you
know what i they i have to do i have to
because i work for them well you hear
this
because i work for them uh they i'm i
have to file as a foreign agent
oh really yeah
now they don't make people on al jazeera
do that they don't make people on uh any
of these uh the bbc don't have to do
that so the irs is making you do that oh
no the government oh the government's
not the irs irs has nothing to do with
it okay it's the government we have to
file with the department of justice
now i take offense to that yeah
i'm born and raised here i'm a united
states citizen i've been a mayor i've
been a governor i'm an honorably
discharged vietnam veteran and i have
paid taxes to this country my entire
adult life unlike donald trump yeah i
pay my taxes yeah i participate i don't
cheat
so having said that i'm now considered a
foreign agent
right damn
does that kind of stuff make sure at the
start of the show it says how our show
has to be it's cleared by the department
of justice it has to go to them is it
really yeah
yeah well they ain't done nothing i mean
i say what i want to say
but i'm sure i'm on some list and i'm
sure i'm under observation
you know
from these bozos
and yet i stand up for him yeah against
the insurrection does it make you feel
like i used to feel like when i was
younger and stuff when i was a kid
that's why we gone we're having fun here
how long about 45 minutes oh so we got
15 to go then wow
that's about the time i'll run out of
voice man okay no worries um i used to
feel like as a kid like there was this
american dream there was this red white
and blue thing and we're all part of
this group like and sometimes i feel
like i don't feel that way anymore
sometimes and it's not like i don't know
if it's a choice i'm making not to feel
that way you know what made me change
way back when i s when
during vietnam when i saw the draft
it was the draft because the rich kids
didn't have to go yeah donald trump got
bought his way out of it yeah he he was
going to get drafted and his dad went
and paid off and he got bone spurs
really he's never missed a round of golf
he probably got him in his penis i bet
bone spurs in his feet yeah and yet i've
never seen him miss around the gulf
could you imagine him though with a well
bone spurs would be painful how the hell
could he play golf he'd bring a sandwich
a gutsy guy what a gutsy to withstand
that pain
and swing that golf club i mean there's
a true tough leader isn't that
what would you do if you didn't have
high interest loans huh imagine
imagine what you'd be doing out there
with your cash getting something for
yourself get you a couple
candies or something get your little
cousin a little butterfinger get him a
new baseball mitt
you could do a lot
if you're carrying a credit balance
month after month oh that's heavy
that's that django baby you don't want
it it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt
with no end in sight
that ain't you fam
upstart
is the fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan
all online you have to go anywhere
changing your credit changing your
financial
picture without going anywhere
rather than looking at credit score
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan they do the work
yup loans between 1000 to 50 000. find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today go to upstart.com
theo that's
upstart.com t-h-e-o
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain
information provided in your land
application upstart.com
theo
the holidays are right around the corner
and if you don't believe that then just
go ask
anybody
anybody will tell you that
and it's that time to give somebody
something
something that means something
especially in this busy world you want
to make a connection with your loved
ones
that's why
paintyourlife.com
you can have an original painting
by a world-class artist done by hand
from any photo
at an affordable price
now think about that you have a photo
you love maybe it's you and grandma out
there doing badminton or you guys
you know
you and uh you and your cousin having a
cigarette on the porch after work
could be anything well
you can get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at an
affordable price
send in any picture
or combine photos into one painting with
paint your life's compilation portraits
you can bring together family members
who never even had the chance to meet
very special
yep at paint your life dot com there's
no risk if you don't love the final
painting your money's refunded
guaranteed and right now as a limited
time offer get twenty percent off your
painting that's right twenty percent off
and free shipping
to get this special offer text the word
weekend
to six four dash zero zero zero
that's weekend w-e-e-k-e-n-d
to six four dash zero zero zero text
weekend to 64-000
paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
and support the podcast
you know
do you feel like the leadership that we
have in now is
no
they're all as bad the dems and repubs i
side with ralph nader yeah who called it
correctly when he said we're under the
rule of a two-party dictatorship yeah
and the reason i say that is because you
notice there's no problem passing the
defense bill right boy they all jump on
board for that don't they because
they're all making money no argument
about that how about the latest did you
hear the latest were 31 of them they
passed a law in 2012 they are not
allowed to trade stocks on the stock
market and invest right
31 of them just got caught for insider
trading
you know what the biggest penalty
they're going to face
a 200 fine yeah
after they probably made hundreds of
thousands on the stock market they'll
pay a 200 fine now it seems to me
charlie sheen went to jail in wall
street for that yeah remember oliver's
movie oliver stone's movie wall street
oh yes i remember it charlie sheen went
to jail for insider trading for you know
and then he got a lighter sentence
because he turned gekko over to him yeah
you know gordon gekko so he cooperated
but that is against the law and the
point is all 37 of these people should
be made to resign right now
and i'll tell you why because it is so
basic that when you get elected you do
not make decisions and do not to profit
yourself right and when you're doing
insider trading trading that nobody else
knows about but you he's cheating that's
cheating and that's illegal and people
go to prison for it and 37 of our
illustrious elected officials you notice
how these guys go in there they're not
millionaires many of them but they all
come out millionaires yeah well those
jobs don't pay that much
i'll tell you this that's the reason i
didn't one of the major reasons i didn't
seek a second term as governor you know
how much money i was making probably 2
000 a week
how much 25
no i'll tell you exactly okay
the governor got paid a hundred and
twenty thousand a year okay so about two
dollars a week now they're going to take
taxes out right okay well i also get
deducted
mileage for the official governor's car
unless during the work day
so to and from the capital
i have to pay for it till i get to the
capitol
so wait so i went to them and said well
okay i'll drive my private car to the
capitol and then i'll get in the
governor's car and i won't get doc money
public safety comes into catch 22. you
can't do that
why well that's the car with all the
protection and the radios and all this
so they make you ride in the car and
then charge you for it oh damn and it
don't end there
the governor's residence
every meal that me and my family ate
there was deducted from my paycheck i
had to turn in weekly things on how many
meals
were served to me and my family at the
governor's residence unless it was
official
state business so that would get
deducted
it ended up here okay get ready now i'm
in charge of a 16 billion dollar budget
right
i cl i was clearing at best
60 grand a year
wow
now jesse ventura has a lifestyle
that if i'm making 60 grand a year
i'm sinking yeah
i'm not even treading water right i'm
sinking yeah
you know and that was one of the major
and i wouldn't corrupt i suppose i could
have been corrupt and who knows what i
might have made and what kind of job i
would have gotten
after i got out because you know they
always seem to land on their feet with
some real great paying job oh yeah
nobody can you know the the greatest
thing i got getting on office the thing
i hold in the highest esteem
i got to be a fellowship professor at
harvard
2004. and how did that work how did that
come to they sent me a letter oh yeah
and they said how would you like to
teach in the john f kennedy
school of government at harvard
university honestly when i turned to my
wife i said is this for freaking real
i said i only went to high school
i went in the navy of high school
they're asking me to come and teach at
harvard they need teachers i think
everywhere no no no no this is 2 000. oh
yeah they have no teachers this is
harvard they don't need teachers at
harvard no shortage there
you know
and and so i i took it for the whole
year they they paid me a stipend i got
paid every month they moved me into an
apartment on the business school right
on campus and i would walk across the
charles river every morning to an office
i had i learned how to do the computer
there and i actually sent an email and
then as soon as i left harvard i forgot
the computer and haven't sent an email
since
you know sir harvard taught me that and
i quickly forgot it do you know i've
never owned a cell phone really
and i've made it my life's mission now i
do i will not own one i will do
everything in my power not to get one
wow i want to be able to put on my
gravestone he never owned a cell phone
and i figure if i last 10 more years
you got it i may be the only person on
the planet that can write that damn
although i am running into some people
that say their grandparents
are holding out yeah they're holding out
so i got to outlive them yeah let's just
start off with that's the key now i
gotta outlive the the elder least
[Music]
but no i've never hit man people have
said to me well how could you be
governor
simple and it was even better
i had two bodyguards 24 7. they had them
yeah so they screened calls
anybody wants to talk to me they call
them
that edit that it they cover
governor so and so is calling oh
tell him i'll call him back at five that
i'm busy right now but i will get back
to him i'm sorry the governor is not
available right now but he is aware of
your situation and said he'll get back
to you at five o'clock today okay very
good thank you
that way you got a built-in yes call
screener if you got your own cell phone
oh you're it's the worst you ain't got a
call screen you don't have a life
anymore either
i gotta ask you this well you know it's
interesting
i've gone i've said that to people and
people have looked at me and they've
actually looked at me sincerely and
replied you're lucky wow oh yeah i often
think to myself why are they saying that
to me why are they telling me i'm lucky
not to have a cell phone and i think
it's because
it's it's beginning to dominate people's
lives
to where they have nothing else but the
cell phone yeah
boy i'd hate that existence i went out
to serious radio once and you know they
put you in the green room oh yeah i've
been i always hated the new york do you
like the green room i hate it i don't
like it that much no you know why i hate
the green room why because that's what
they call the room at san quentin where
they put you to death oh really it's
called the green room oh damn that's
where they go before they pump you full
of electricity oh the old days well
anyway i'm at the green room at sirius
right there's probably a dozen people
there every one of them is staring at
their cell phone but me
and i'm looking around the room and i
finally thought
screw this
so i did what i needed to do to
command the room and i looked at him and
said have any of you noticed in this
room that i'm the only person here not
looking at a cell phone
and they all look around at each other
sheepishly
i just kind of shake my head i just
wanted to bring it to their attention
it's a freedom and i was the only person
in this room of a dozen people who
wasn't staring yeah or doing
manipulating something
on you know oh yeah thank god we sent
captain kirk up to space now because now
it's timely everybody's got the
communicators right that they add on
star trek yeah yeah yeah the only thing
you can't do now is send yourself places
but i'm sure that's common
you know i interviewed him captain kirk
oh yeah and he passed away didn't he no
he just went to space oh thank god
no no no he just went up
william shatner just went into space oh
yeah yeah
dude i forget about that i always think
of uh i knew him from rescue 9-1-1 he's
captain james t kirk of the starship
enterprise mr spock is dead yeah you
know but captain kirk of the we grew up
to that in the 60s that was the coolest
show on tv it was star trek
james t kirk my wife had a crush on him
when she was a young girl she told me
she said i was in love with and i you
know and captain kirk yeah james t kirk
of this and no i thought and it was kind
of interesting because
i saw a huge scientist interviewed
and they asked him how he felt about
william shatner being going into space
like that
he looked and smiled and he said
something really cool he goes
william shatner didn't go into space he
said james t kirk went into school oh
that's cool
a certain part of him
i just thought that was so cool that
this scientist said
william shatner didn't go into space
james t kirk went into space
yeah i like that a little bit of the
mystique keeping it alive yeah he went
into space it's hard to keep mystique
alive when you watch star trek you know
that man's been to space
and he came do you hear his message
take care of our planet wow he came back
so he said
and you know what i've heard everybody
that goes up there comes back
a total greenie
stop the destruction of our planet
because they're seeing out there nothing
but drab dead
and they look back on this blue thing
that shines
with life
when you're out there there ain't no
life
or at least we ain't found it yet yeah
you know and there is but we ain't found
it yet yeah you know you think they're
out but they said when you look of
course
read neil's book lately
i'm just saying from just a lame the
universe is so large yeah oh do you know
what else it was i don't
here's what ticks me off now you got
this whole thing in schools where they
don't want to teach the truth yeah they
don't want to teach the truth now they
want to gloss it over so the white
people can feel good yeah right
it's ridiculous do you know what i
learned now too
we here okay
for years we celebrate columbus day
he discovered america
and i ding myself in the head and go it
took me how long to realize
how can you discover something if
there's already somebody there
right
you didn't discover nothing
there was already people there but why
did we used to have it that way then it
was just an easy way to explain it it's
all we know because there was they
didn't have a flag uh you could have a
flag man you got to buy as eddie izzard
will tell you that you know how to use
it yeah watch eddie eddie you'll explain
it you've got to have don't have a flag
but no you're getting back to it again
you you know where are we going now i'm
getting old now uh um well we're talking
about uh i don't know we're talking
about a lot of different things i wanted
the last thing i wanted to make the uh
the the space is there people out there
oh yeah yeah okay
you you look at the situation now and i
read the other people out there oh i
know columbus so not only did columbus
not discover america you know what else
was total bs we got taught what was it
that he that he went there believing the
earth was flat
oh that's a lie that's a complete lie
neil shows where they knew centuries
before columbus that the world wasn't
flat damn bruh but yet in all our school
books
that's what we read oh columbus
discovered america and they sent him to
find out because they were terrified he
was gonna fall off the end of the earth
it was flat
oh our teacher even made a thing where
he went up the side and then turned onto
the corner get neal's book
he lays it right out when we knew the
world wasn't flat and it happened
literally probably 800 years before
columbus even sailed
they knew that that scholars knew the
earth was not flat yeah
i think something so why were we taught
that okay that's a good
question
i want to what to make you know what
angered me
here's what's got me in a roar about
this and why i'm saying you teach it
it took me 69 years to learn that we
massacred black people in tulsa yeah
well i learned that last year
i was 69 years old when i learned that
right that is the first i have known of
that in 69 years
on this planet
yeah i got angry
why wasn't i taught about that in school
right
why is that not written in a hit well
here's one for you did you know there
was a coup d'etat attempt on president
roosevelt
by wall street
because it's been eradicated raced set
aside major general smedley butler saved
our country damn the two-time
congressional medal of honor winner he
was hand-picked chosen to be the
president damn young but you know what
smedley did smedley went in front of
congress and ratted him he whistle blew
him smedly said fdr is my president i'm
a republican he's a democrat
he's a two-time congressional medal of
honor marine general smedley goes
he's still my president
even though i'm in a different party
this is treason right and he turned
these guys over all the rothschild all
these names these big names on the wall
they had hand-picked smedley butler why
because fdr was bringing in these
socialist programs what does wall street
fear anything that's socialist
and we here in the u.s fear everything
socialist don't we yet here's one for
you guys time to learn from jesse
our biggest part of our budget that you
and i pay taxes on is for total
socialism like you know what that is
the department of defense yeah that's
total socialism
at its finest
so you have socialism protecting the
capitalism
damn it's a dark art and yet people are
telling you i'm scared they're turning
the country's socialist right well
she what you need if you have all
capitalism you're going to fail we saw
that on wall street i think we're still
seeing it
you have to have a balance yeah you have
to achieve a balance between capitalism
and socialism that raises the most
people up right
that's when you have a great society so
all these people that fear socialism
you're very military i was a navy seal
guess what
other than
combat pay and special pay for things i
did my base pay
for being a navy seal was the same as
the base pay of a cook wow i don't get
paid no more if he's the same rank as me
doesn't matter that i'm on seal team and
he's over frying hamburgers
now i did make extra money because they
give us hazardous duty pay for jump but
get this you only get two of the three
i was qualified for all three hazardous
dudes
they only let you have two and guess
what officers get paid twice as much now
tell me that ain't socialism
why does an officer get paid twice as
much as me he jumps out of the same
plane yeah
you know but he does no i i would get 55
extra a month for jumping
and i'd get 55 extra month for
demolition pay i got paid nothing for
diving wow and diving's supposed to be
an extra 85 a month
but they only allow us to get two of the
three
why i don't know they make us do all
three yeah
you know but one of them i have to do
for good old uncle sam that's on the
house
that's that's a charity one i get to all
the diving i do under the water that was
for charity
i got a couple questions that these are
things that i think people need to hear
and hearing from you i think are very
important right um
you talk a lot about how like the
two-party system how it's one of the
things that's definitely failing us and
you've been an example of being an
independent right what don't people
understand about even just voting for an
independent whether you even almost
believe in them or not what can that do
to change the current
system that we have like well really
truly truthfully it's simplicity i think
in voting
and if everyone would just stick to the
simplicity of it
vote your conscience
don't pick a winner
your job when you vote isn't to go there
to vote for the who you think's gonna
win
your job in voting is to go there and
pick out the candidate whom you think
would best represent your point of view
yeah and vote for that person if that
person gets beat you did still did your
civic duty
you voted now if you vote for somebody
else you're selling out yeah if you vote
the two party like if you find some
third person who thinks way more like
you and has better ideas that you go
with but yet you still vote but well he
can't win well one thing i proved is
yeah if you get the most votes you can
win yeah
it just takes getting the most votes
right
it was like when i ran
they told me this is back in 98. they
told me
forget the young people they don't vote
i told them book me at every college in
the state of minnesota yeah
and they said you're wasting your time
then the guys with the
i said no i ain't yes and i'll tell you
why
they said why i said because the college
kids have never had jessie the body to
vote for
are you kidding me
so they booked me in all the colleges
i'd go there packed to the hilt kids
hanging off the rafters you know when i
knew i was gonna win and they were your
age because you're talking 20 years ago
so this is your generation
uh here's when i knew i was gonna win
that day we got there the morning of the
election and at the university of
minnesota they said the lines to
register were longer than the lines to
vote because in minnesota we have
same-day registration
and the lines to register were longer
than the lines to vote
that's when i knew we're gonna win
because they ain't coming out to vote
for a democrat or republican they're
they're already registered these are new
people and
it ended up i won by
i was polling 10 percent
it was not a presidential so they
predicted a 50 voter turnout
non-presidential which is pathetic right
but it still leads the nation minnesota
does every year really oh yeah us and
maine we battle it out for the most
percentage to vote
well people come if people here come out
and vote yeah
yep and uh and what happened was
they predicted a 50 voter turnout
because it wasn't presidential so a lot
of people stay home
it ended up 60. i was polling 27
the day before i ended up winning with
37 because remember there's three people
now
so the percentages change i had 37 the
republican had 34 the dem ended up with
28.
but my 27 to 37 that was the 10
they didn't expect to show up yeah
because they predicted a 50 voter turn
it turned out it was 60 and though and
those 10 came voting for me
well i'll never forget the headline in
the minneapolis paper ventura wins
sub headline underneath remember i told
you about the colleges
throngs of young voters turn out
throngs that was the term they used it's
like you sliding in the ring with a
chair dude well it was like i went out
and see as a getting back to your
original question third party
that's what uh you they all that's what
you've got to tap into beat them right
you're not going to beat their bases
right you've got to get and but most
people are independent
we're be you know what angers me right
now the most of anything
our country is being governed and
stopped from doing anything by those 50
people in the senate the 50 republicans
right
i don't know well then they got to do
that they call where you need 60
votes or whatever what do you mean you
don't know you better start knowing i'm
trying to anyway
okay 50 republicans block everything
right
here's what pisses me off
because there's an equal amount of
senators two in each state do you know
those 50 republicans how much of the
population they actually represent and
they're stopping the rest of the country
they represent 21 of the population wow
because you have states like north and
south dakota that have the same senate
two people as california
as
new york
so they have equal to them they can stop
them that's insane
now it was initially i know why it was
done so it was equality amongst the 13
original states right but when
california has a huge population and new
york has a huge population how can they
be equal
to south dakota
but then do you worry that by the way i
see more south dakota license plates in
mexico than i see in south dakota
you know why that is
because south dakota don't give a
if you live there or not you can just
license your car there so all these
people from california that are supposed
to bring them back for emission tests
because they still have them there you'd
have to drive the whole baja to do that
every year well they leave them down
there and they just register them in
south dakota wow so you see south dakota
plates all over the bar like i said
there's more south dakotans in the baja
than there is in south dakota
what um
you also you talk a lot about south
dakota just wants the money they don't
go crap where you live they'll license
you and that's great fine no problem for
me yeah a lot of places have different
little loopholes like that sure just a
way to make money um
what about um you talk i've heard you
speak about uh about tax at the point of
purchase you know which is i've lost
yes that that's the way we should do it
it would keep all these loopholes and
all this everybody spend money
would pay their taxes and you'd live
within your means right how do you
because after you explain that to people
who don't understand why
when i really got into it it was i think
representative army from texas dick army
was his name he brought i learned it he
brought it i learned it when he brought
it up
a national sales tax is like a state
sales tax what it would do
you could throw away all the records you
have to keep for seven years of income
you wouldn't have to keep them you would
never be audited again
all of that would be gone
the tax at that time would have been 12
percent
well that would then keep our government
on budget with the economy they'd have
to ensure the economy stays good
otherwise they don't get their money do
they right but when they have an income
tax they get their money whether the
economy is good or not ah see
this way they would be directly
correlated with the economy
now it would be then maybe it'd be a
little more now but 12 it's a lot less
than i'm paying now yeah
so you would pay that at the point of
purchase now
businesses are already doing that so you
as an individual would never have to
keep a tax return again you'd never have
to file one let's stress everything you
do would be done at the point of
purchase buying right now your car would
cost and it would make you more
conscious of living in your means
because you'd you'd see a price on the
car that you go holy it's up 12
because i have to pay a 12 sales tax to
the federal government yeah well guess
who else would pay that tourists
everybody
right now tourists don't pay federal tax
here right they would if you have a
launch sales tax
and bought something and there'd be a
federal
sales tax on everything and get this you
wouldn't have to put it on food right
and you wouldn't have to put it on
clothing say under 100 bucks
now if you buy a mink stole or by
dripping with diamonds yeah you're going
to pay right but you could buy your
underwear your blue jeans and your
t-shirts you ain't going to walk around
naked and you wouldn't have to pay tax
and i notice all of us are dressed that
way today so we wouldn't have to pay no
tax on none of the clothes any of us are
wearing i love that man how far is that
ever opposite they'll never do it yeah
they'll never do it because the rich
people don't pay anyway they pay lawyers
instead so they don't have to pay
and and uh
and okay then here's the other thing
people said to me okay
what would you do with irs then
they'd be gone right no
you turn their job around
instead of the irs watching us the
people you make them watch the
businesses and the government to ensure
they're collecting and using our taxes
correctly yeah they be the irs then
becomes our watchdog
of the government and business god we
need that yes
why do you think it won't pass
because it's because
it's common sense it makes sense
and if i can quote charles manson
no sense makes sense yeah and that's a
quote from charles mann is it really
yeah yeah it did he said that one time
no sense misunderstood a little bit
no sense think about it no sense makes
sense that's how they operate yeah no
sense makes sense yeah
you know but no a national sales tax you
couldn't cheat on it yeah because it
everything you bought and sold
would have to require
right you have to be able to pay for it
pay right then roughly let's just say 12
15 let's get high 15 percent well i'm
paying way more than 15 percent right
now right so at least yeah i love you
don't pay nothing 15 yeah
now and then they said oh it'll hurt
poor people worse because it's
regressive yes but you know you can do
with it what you want
you could find out say
what a person's at in poverty right so a
person in poverty say if their income
they don't make that much money you
could give them their first twenty
thousand dollars of purchases no taxes
you could give them a credit card right
that but anything beyond that if they
start living beyond their means
then they get taxed yeah but you you
could see the thing you can make it
anything you want it and you can give
breaks where
you feel you need it to help poor people
right you know you could give them their
first 12 000 and purchase no tax yeah
you know if you're under 25 000 in
income yeah you know we'll give you your
first half if you spend half yeah we'll
help you out yeah you don't have to pay
tax on nothing oh yeah you know you can
survive but then the big people that buy
yachts and buy mercedes
all that hit them up yeah thick boys
shoes or whatever they're buying yeah
buying all that fancy crap well you pay
for it yeah
you know if that's your lifestyle well
then live your lifestyle enjoy it yeah
and it would force people to live within
their budgets
forced them to they couldn't buy
something they'd have to say jesus i'm
gonna have to make more money to go if i
want this yeah you know i can't afford
this i love that man i feel like it's
called
yeah and you abolish the income tax do
any countries do it i don't know yeah i
don't know but you think how nice i i
carry
i've got i've got i was cleaning out
i've got crap that goes back 25
years in my attic papers shredding it
and i have to sit and spend an entire
afternoon shredding documents i feel
like i'm in watergate oh yeah it's like
a thing with nixon
yeah
they were just ridiculous on that so
yeah the national sales tax i've
advocated for that since 1990. no people
need to know i just i think a lot of
people don't even know that it's a
possibility oh well it ain't a
possibility because they're not going to
do it right you know you you would have
to vote all them creeps out of office
and get a whole bunch of new people in
there
but the new generation could do that do
it it's up to you guys come to us for
the advice
but it's going to be up to you guys to
do it to the practicality yeah now i
love some of that information
we're too old to carry the ball now yeah
we can be the coaches we can be up in
the press box we can map the game out
for you but it's you 40 and unders 50s
and unders that got to pick that ball up
and run with it you got to play the game
now do you believe that things can
change
i believe that they can but i don't i i
i tell you
because you're very optimistic for even
somebody in your your age
i shouldn't say that i am
uh it's the first time in my life that i
don't see the united states with a
better future in the future
that i don't see
as much light
as i used to i always would see
light at the tunnel yeah but right now
because
because there's so much lying
and there's so much deceit
and people don't know what to believe
and what not to believe yeah that's the
scariest part
and our government causes it yeah and
they cause it by things that like how
come john f kennedy they still have
documents on that right it's 60 years
ago yeah yeah and and and and that and
i'll even say 9 11.
yeah because i have questions on both of
those events
and nobody seems to be able to answer
them adequately for me
and
what troubles me about those and maybe
we'll finish with this to make people
think on it
is if the stories they told us are true
right
in the case of kennedy and in the case
of 911 if those are the truth what we
were told
then why would anything have to be
withheld because of national security
yeah the truth should be just the truth
what what national if okay if lee oswald
was a lone nut and did what they said he
did
why would any documents have to be held
for national security he was a he was a
little private and then marines yeah he
wasn't a general who had sensitive
goofballs well he was at a base where
they you two flights and all or white
beaters too i remember but but then you
look to 911 and you go okay
here's what they told us to accept
right now listen to this
this is what they told us
that 19 islamic radicals
armed with box cutters
defeated our multi-billion dollar air
defense system
all while conspiring with a bearded guy
in a cave in afghanistan yeah and we
accepted that
hook line and sinker now
i have a hard time
accepting that
for a couple reasons first of all we've
then been screwed because if we've paid
billions of dollars
for
security
and you can defeat it with box cutters
yeah
we got screwed out of our money second
of all
when i was governor of minnesota
if we would have had a disaster
at a state level that would have been
equivalent to that
and it could have been prevented
don't you think somebody should get
fired
and yet on 9 11
not one person lost their job
not one person was even demoted
over this gross derelict of duty
protecting us
and the whole thing
and in fact nobody was demoted the
opposite occurred people got promoted
how does that work
i said when i was in the navy seals
we had a simple thing that failure was
not an option yeah
and i would think air defense failure is
not an option
whoever was in charge of our air defense
and allowed 18 islamic radicals with box
cutters to defeat it should have lost
their job shouldn't they yeah well you
know why they don't lose their jobs
that's how people start talking that's
how whistleblowers start that's how
information starts being developed if
you lost your job and nobody else did
you're going to be pissed you're going
to say wait a minute i did this i did
that but so-and-so told me to do this
and all of a sudden you've got
people turning over other people and
pretty soon it leads to higher places
yeah well if you don't want that to
happen don't fire no one right and every
and busine the day goes on as normal the
next day everyone's back to work
everybody thinks they did everything
fine yeah not even knowing they might
have been in something and they didn't
get fired nobody got don't you don't you
guys think somebody should have got
fired yeah oh yeah there's a catastrophe
like that that we invest billions of
dollars in yeah and we got beer defense
and they can go with box cutters and
take three planes and smash them crazy
now
well i i'll i'll leave you with why am i
i'll leave you with this one
you all familiar with conspiracy theory
yeah my tv show or did i get in trouble
oh i know eddie bravo the guy yeah you
know well i spoke to a woman
sergeant april gallup
uh top secret crypto security clearance
she was in the room
that the alleged plane hit the pentagon
right
she looked me right in the eye and told
me there was no plane
what
well
did you ever see one no no all you saw
was a hole and then they covered it up
with a tarp there was no wings there was
no debris on the lawn outside there was
no place where the wings hit the
building to sever them
if all you saw was this big hole yeah
that they covered up she looked at me
she said there was no plane
she said there was no luggage there was
no seats there were no bodies
she staggered out the hole and was
recovered on the lawn and the government
immediately put her into 72-hour
solitary confinement where she couldn't
talk to nobody
yeah
and she told me there was no plane she
said she thought she did it
because she said i was at work i went in
that day she said i was working on my
computer and she said right when i'd hit
this particular button the whole room
blew up
and her initial thought was her computer
was wired to a bomb wow but she doesn't
believe that now
you know that it was right but that's
what happened and she said through all
there was no plan what does she believe
now she don't she won't she will just
tell you there was no plane right
which is all she knows she doesn't know
what did it she doesn't know how it was
done
she just is clear
that there was not a plane and when you
look at the thing if they superimposed
the plane with the hole
it would the engines would have dug big
trenches through the dirt before it
struck because the engines are lower
than the hole right
and they would have been down in the
dirt digging a trench there were no
trenches out there plus those planes
have components out of carbon titanium
steel which is the hardest substance
known to man when it hits cement the
cement breaks the carbon titanium steel
don't
where's the debris yeah
yeah you never even heard about it well
who can we
here's another one for you
these are the only planes that have ever
gone down
where they never tried to put them with
the pieces back resurrect them back
together again
even though they should have had plenty
of pieces yeah never was an attempt even
done
to put that where they always do that in
a plane crash oh it's the big thing they
do that's the huge thing they do lo and
behold in this day 9 11 that wasn't done
that i need an answer to
here's the final one
prior to 911
base commanders
had the ability to scramble jets in
other words if they got a call from the
faa
that something was wrong up in the air a
base commander could order and scramble
jets happened all the time and what does
that mean when they scramble a jet epco
jets to find out what's going on okay
fighters okay so so they could send
injections
that'll put you in okay they're sending
fighter jets up tom cruise oh yeah just
going airborne goose daddy just
[Laughter]
anyway
uh base commanders had the ability to do
that okay correct yes
till june
of 2001.
in june of 2001 there was an executive
order
that the only person that could scramble
planes was donald rumsfeld the secretary
of defense
[Music]
had to come from donny
that happened in june
9 11 happens
interesting they couldn't find rummy for
hours
rummy was unavailable
so no planes could go into the air
9 11 happens
one month later guess what the policies
put back to the old of june first
now the base commanders can scramble
planes again
but for that three-month period in there
they weren't allowed to
i'd like an answer to that question and
why an executive order went out to did
that
yeah and that why was it reinstated
after 9 11 took place
and who who can we trust then who can we
trust i don't know got to trust yourself
yeah you got to do your own work yeah
you know
you gotta and and let me add this
everything i did on conspiracy theory i
didn't necessarily believe in all of it
you gotta remember this entertainment
this is a tv show right you know
like i everyone's getting on me now
because my show predicted the pandemic
right
really yeah this
woman from south america i had her on
she was with that general
that with the
all that crazy stuff what the petraeus
no the people that talk to goats oh uh
general
i forget his name
it's not the vietnamese guy no no no
he's got this real long name he's like a
he's like a mystique person within the
u.s military oh dang i don't even know
well he came up here with his wife who's
a doctor i had interviewed them in a
hangar on i forget what subject it was
and she told me there's going to be a
pandemic damn within the next six years
and sure enough there was and that's why
everyone's yelling at me that i'm a
turncoat now because i got vaccinated
yeah how does that make me a turncoat
yeah you know i i look at it from
i look at it from the odds and when it's
ten to one you're going to die
unless you get a vaccination
i'm going with the good odds i'm not
gonna test the bad ones i'm 70 years old
now yeah
yeah we need you here and and you know
i'm not going to
i'm going to get my booster coming up
here
no problem people said they hadn't
bothered me you know the only thing that
bothered me getting the shots
my deltoid got sore yeah well guess what
when they stick a piece of metal in rock
solid ripped muscle
you know it gets sore yeah by the way
you know it's been good for me in the
pandemic working out yeah i'm 220 i'm in
the bed i got i got a six-pack because
you're 70 years old
how many people can say at 70 they got a
six-pack baby not a lot of yeah
why because there's nothing else to do
yeah now you know i've been banned from
the price is right
oh yeah because i watch it while i work
out every day i know the price of every
car on there baby
i want to see you guys i watch drew
carey he's one of my favorites he's
great i
that is on every morning that i train
whether i'm on the elliptic or doing my
weights
you carry and the price is right and
then andy mayberry oh yeah he's good you
know i went to the hospital buying my
wife a t-shirt guys oh she hates barney
fife oh really yeah she hates him so i'm
getting her a t-shirt i hate barney
fights
he's from north carolina did you south
carolina he's from south carolina yeah
that's mayberry south carolina they
north carolina there's a stat no the the
guy is actually from whoever played andy
griffith oh maybe he is but mayberry
itself was supposedly in south carolina
oh yeah there's a statue of south
carolina and uh this by the way you
heard that uh north carolina they took
down robert e lee's uh
statue right in virginia oh yeah finally
yeah yeah do you know what trump said
uh-uh donald with his vast military
knowledge and experience you know i i
give him a lot of
credit and credibility here's a trump
comment you didn't hear what he said oh
he come out and said that lee was a
great general and had we had him we'd
have won in afghanistan
he said this you guys are laughing he
said this but he could he he oh my first
question would have been true we must
really be getting bad history because if
i recollect right didn't lee lose yeah
in the civil war
so shouldn't we have sent ulysses grant
over to afghanistan
he's the guy that won
you know
robert e lee lost
yeah sometimes we don't even think about
that why would trump want to send the
guy who lost
i don't think that man thought a lot
before i don't think trump was a big
thinker why do you think so many people
gravitated towards trump because i know
a lot of people i don't love trump and
they're not all dummies they're not all
idiots a lot of them are good people i
don't know i'm trying to figure out if
it's fluoride in the water
because i've never had fluoride in my
water do you think he just sounded like
how do you know what that is floyd in
the water no i think we have them put
fluoride in all water
sure they do for your teeth so you don't
get cavities fluoride goes into all
drinking water oh i got cavities well do
you know what fluoride's the major
ingredient of
i've never had because all the homes and
it wasn't by design but every house i've
lived in i've had my own well yeah and
you can send at the university of
minnesota and the kids in chemistry will
test your water free wow or at minimal
price because they got to have things to
do they're in chemistry classes
so they'll you know they'll break down
your water you can do it at the
university send it over there and
they'll give you a whole breakdown of
what's in your well water wow
well uh uh the thing is i've had well
water my whole life i've never been
hooked up to city water and none of the
houses and city water like the city of
brainerd where fargo was from they got a
big fight years ago they didn't want to
fluoridate their water the feds came in
and made them wow didn't even get the
option
well here's the deal do you know what
fluoride's the major ingredient of
prozac
oh damn
so if you're drinking fluorinated water
on a daily basis you're getting a daily
supply of prozac
because that's the major ingredient in
prozac what's prozac for to calm you
down right yeah take away
anxiety i guess i never usually take
away your ideas i think maybe that's a
certain point dumb you down oh it really
sedates your brain after a while yeah
and if you're drinking
fluoridated water every day
fluoride's the major ingredient in
prozac
what does prozac do yeah i don't know
that i'm not a chemist yeah all i can
tell you is it's the major ingredient
of prozac is fluoride
i'm not shocked
everything's scary now oh well it was
scary then too was it always scary sure
we have the draft do you think it's just
new scary we have the draft i grew up in
south minneapolis right
if you grew up in south minneapolis and
you had to go to work for a living
because your parents weren't rich guess
what you were going to vietnam right if
you grew up out in edina
minnetonka with the fat cats where al
franken grew up oh yeah oh yeah yeah
well then you went then you went to uh
harvard you were fine you went to blake
indiana university no you went to blake
school here in minneapolis
college
well those kids didn't worry about
vietnam they went to college and got
deferments and got out of it remember
dick cheney got like six deferments out
of vietnam
and they asked him and dick's response
was well i had other priorities
i heard that and said well so did every
other kid that got drafted why do you
think they got drafted for christ's sake
yeah they had other priorities yeah you
know me i was a dummy i went and
enlisted
do you know the navies never drafted
oh really nope so only the armies
drafted army and the marines and all
that
a lot of people when there was the draft
a lot of people would join the navy
because with the navy you're at least
guaranteed three hots and a cot oh yeah
you know you're gonna get a bed and
you're gonna get three hot meals a day
you're not gonna be laying in the dirt
yeah but then you can do what i did and
go into volunteer for what they call the
brown water navy and then you probably
well we had it better than the army
though in the end because all of our
operations were one-nighters we don't go
out but the marines are those hitmen the
marines come in and they're the hitmen
no we are
i mean you're going to understand
something i don't
there's a there's a the marines claim
they're first ashore right
they're not
want me to sing you i'll end you with a
song okay that'll piss off all the
marines
because we used to piss them off anyway
let's keep they never liked us you
frogmen seals to begin with let's keep
it going here's here's a here's a song
we used to sing
in tr in udt seal training okay and it's
entitled marines drowning in the waves
okay
now you know that udt stands for
underwater demolition tea
okay okay and we're in buds is called
basic underwater demolition slash seal
okay you know
because the seals came about in 62 when
kennedy took the frogmen out of the
water and put them on land wow and so
they needed a name and they came up with
sea air land because will come from the
sea will come from the air will come
from the land
see our land that's what seal stands for
and this is a song we would sing in
training
called marines drowning in the waves
it goes
marines drowning in the waves it's udt
who always saves and when a job they
cannot do
it's u-d-t
pulls it through
although they claim
they're first ashore
udt's been there before all
leathernecks on bended knees can kiss
the ass of udts
now
here's the tradition
we came about because in world war ii
you know those landing boats with the
marines that flop the front down and the
marines charge off on the beach
well they did one of them and there was
a sand bar
and when the boats went down they hit
the sandbar when they dropped their
front i forget hundreds of marines ran
off and drowned
because they ran into deep water nobody
knew the sandbar was there
so they needed to form the underwater
demolition teams now the blowing up came
from obstacles the enemy would put in
the water to stop those we would blow
them up but we also would recon the
beach to show where the boats could go
in
so they wouldn't hit a sand bar and
potentially kill these brave marines
that are charging the beach and don't
get me wrong they i wouldn't do it
they're brave as hell yeah i'll go in
before them any day yeah i don't want to
be charging with them yeah you know i'll
go in in the dark
but what became a tradition
especially in the pacific
was that when the marines were gonna
land the udt watch the frogmen
with richard
when the udt would do the reconnaissance
at some point during the reconnaissance
one one or two frog men with a pre-made
sign they carried with them would skin
up onto the beach to the high water mark
they'd pound the sign in before they
left in the dark
in the morning when the marines had hit
there would be a sign on the beach
welcome u.s marine corps udt whatever
team it was wow so we would welcome the
marines to that we got there first
that was the way they knew we were
welcoming them so when the marines
claimed their first ashore
been there before now granted we don't
stay yeah we get it
out yeah but we make sure it's okay for
them to charge the next day i see so and
i have all the respect in the world for
oh 100 it sounds like in fact i'll tell
you this
some things i would do we'd get either
helicopters we did a lot of things with
hilos yeah and we'd either get navy
pilots or marine pilots i would always
inquire who's flying us and when they'd
say marines i'd always go good yeah
because i knew
that
if
anything went out of whack
and you called that marine he's coming
wow
he's a marine he gonna come there's
something special you're not gonna think
he's not gonna have second thoughts he's
gonna charge the beach he's a marine
so i always felt better when i knew
marine pilots were flying us yeah we got
a couple of jar heads up there flying us
today that's okay that's good stuff
but uh no it's a natural rival we were
no i love it we were at camp pendleton
once and what i used to hate about it
was they used to send us up there when
the marines had practiced their landings
so we'd have to sit up all day in these
boats if any of them fell in the water
to pull them out yeah you know we're
lifeguards right and we think what the
hell where's marine recon how come they
don't do this what do we got to
come up here and do this all day out in
the sun
bobbing around while they're landing on
the beach you know
and uh well the one time we went up to
pendleton we had master chief corey came
up with us e9 our command master chief
okay that's the highest you can get e9
yeah enlisted yeah your head listed
right well marines don't always know
uniforms very good you know charging the
beach don't require you to know
a lot of other stuff right
and
so an e9 in the navy on his lapel
carries an anchor with two stars on the
anchor the anchor signifies a chief okay
and the two little stars indicate a
senior chief or a master chief okay e9
okay
well corey's walking on the beach with
his master chief two stars and all of a
sudden these marines are running on the
beach and they're stopping boy and
they're popping salutes to corey every
going by right well corey's enlisted man
he's e9
well
then it hit us
they think corey's a two-star admiral
all they're doing is seeing the two
stars up on the lapel
and the marines don't know navy
insignias they think corey's a and word
spread dude it means oh boy the frogmen
got a two-star admiral with them holy
crap right on the beach with them they
got some two-star navy admiral with them
you know so we got anything we wanted
hey we need some stuff oh yeah let's get
some i need a crab leg up here at the
front yeah
well i'll say this and i'll you know i i
was in the naval amphibious base
coronado and that one best chow hall
beautiful over there in the western
pacific for like nine or ten years in a
row you know we you know that shows you
the superiority between the navy and the
rest of the services
every friday at the naval amb base
coronado do you know what we had for
lunch
every friday without fail frog steak and
lobster baby damn they'd cover your
beautiful piece of steak with a lobster
tail god yeah you know what it used to
cost me for that because i i our job
takes us away from the base
so we have to pay to eat on the base we
get what's called comrades in case we
got to eat in town or somewhere yeah
where you know so we get paid so i got
to pay on the base you know what the
stake in lobster would cost me like 85
cents damn
that's a deal bro
yeah
breakfast was like 35 cents
anything you wanted to eat
went to army jump school oh my god if
they didn't have the pizza trucks that
ran around at night i'd have starved to
death really oh the army's horrified
the army jump school they measure out
and you get one scoop of everything you
look at and you go
we got out there the seals and we're
complaining to the army going how are
you supposed to fight if you're not
being fed
cripe almighty we need food we work out
we
burn energy feed us
so they made us do kp one time and boy
we said what is this we said if
the green berets came to our base we
wouldn't make them do kp and you had to
do it well we're in army airborne
schools part of the school
you know which is a joke
i just completed 26 weeks of seal
training and i go out for three weeks at
jump school
we used to get up at five in the morning
and do pt before they'd even get up on
purpose to wake them all up
we'd be out there doing pt the seals are
out at 5am doing pt because they don't
get enough from us damn oh yeah that's
all part of the mystique baby the
mystique back then it was fun they
didn't know us at all
in fact we sent tremors through the rest
of the navy
it was all secretive huh well final
story i went to boot camp and that's
where you go to boot camp
when you go to navy boot camp it's not
difficult right there's nothing hard
there in fact i used to work out and do
push-ups at night because i was getting
out of shape damn
so i'm at boot camp
one day
every day at boot camp you get taught a
different facet of the navy electronics
technician store keeper boats and mate
sonar tech whatever all these different
jobs in the navy
well the one day you get the udt seal
presentation yeah they march three
companies into a room so there's
probably
close to 100 guys in there
yeah close to 100 guys in there and
you're giving the presentation you're
getting oh that we're getting it okay
they march union boot camp
they march you in the room and all of a
sudden these guys come walking out
wearing marine greens spit shine
cochrane jump boots
they don't look navy
and they're all built damn and the guy
walks up chief rashcheck and goes
today gentlemen you're going to hear
about the brown water navy the udt seal
we are the navy special forces
you volunteer to be one of us damn you
can't just be one of us
you have to pass
our test to be one of us
so then they show you showed us a film
called the men with green faces
and you watch this film right it tells
you all about the seals right
and then when you're done with that
he comes back out he says okay
anybody that wants to volunteer for the
udt seal program stay seated
he goes the rest of you
get the out of here damn
there were guys running over each other
getting to the doors yeah because i mean
half of them joined the navy they didn't
want to be doing this
you know what they watched on a film
yeah
going behind enemy lines six guys
all this stuff they didn't want that
there's no
there's no friendlies anywhere wow
that type of work
i'd rather be on the ship but you wanted
it oh you have to have your volunteer
okay probably
i would say
let me think back
30 guys maybe stayed 25 to take this
what they call the screen test
i would say a dozen of us were serious
the other 12 or whatever we're just
doing it to break the monotony of boot
camp yeah
and so then they march you over to the
swimming pool
and you got to line up across the pool
and you got to do a 300 meter swim long
course 50 meter pool
using only an underwater recovery stroke
you can't swim crawl you can't swim
butterfly or backstroke you have to swim
either breaststroke or side stroke
something that doesn't bring your arms
out of the water because you're going to
be doing clandestine swimming so you
can't breathe out of the water no you
can breathe you can't bring your arms oh
you got to be here you don't want to be
splashing you want to underwater
breaststroke is an underwater recovery
stroke hot and go seekers all they see
is your head
if you're swimming the butterfly you're
splashing and you look like a butterfly
coming in on the beach yeah that brings
in tension yeah so you can only do this
swim using an underwater recovery stroke
300 meters
well i was a competitive swimmer
so this was a piece of cake for me and
like a dummy i do it like i'm in the
olympic trials and i win by like a pool
length
i'm going to show these seal instructors
boom i hit the
i'm doing breaststroke like i'm in
the turn the pull under water
[Music]
but i was stupid i wore myself out i
could have cruised
because when i later learned because i
used to give screen tests later when i
learned the time you had to beat i could
have cruised i didn't need to go that
fast
then i would say half of them were gone
at the end of the swim it eliminated
half
we're now down to i think
eight guys wow
they paired us up and you had to do as
many push-ups as you could in two
minutes only resting in the up position
and then the other guy went and you
counted for each other then as many
sit-ups as you could do in two minutes
and then as many four-count burpees as
you could do in two minutes
then they took you over to the to the
track
and you then had to run a mile and again
they don't tell you what's passing
they just say four times around the
track run the mile do you remember how
quick you went i don't know yeah they
didn't have a clock i don't know they
didn't tell you
i ca i won the swim i did great on
everything else i came in third on the
run brettlinger and bueller i even know
the two guys spread linger and bueller
beat me yeah on the run
so
we finished the run they then line up
the eight or ten guys whoever was left
up and they walk down the line with a
clipboard and all he says to you is
either pass or fail damn
four you know how many passed four oh
so you had a hundred guys and only four
guys passed that was just to get to
training damn then when you get to
training each class starts with about a
hundred guys roughly
you will probably graduate 25
wow
it's got a 75 to 80 percent attrition
rate that's all for udt seals oh that's
for seals for both that's all you're all
one oh wow there ain't no difference oh
okay there's no difference there's no
difference it's the same training same
training in my day you then went to a
udt team or a seal team wow and they
generally sent the better swimmers went
to a udt team
because you were gonna do more water
work than a seal would wow so i got sent
to a udt team because i was a good
swimmer yeah and i think back and all
the guys from my class that went with
they were all the best swimmers in the
class
and the instructor told me later yeah i
said oh yeah the best swimmers went to
the udt
the others went to the seals the
stronger swimmers always went to udt
and but you still carried weapons you
still did in fact lots of times we were
the demolition element with the seals
they'd come and get one of us to go with
to set up the explosives
for them you know that's cool and all
that no it ain't cool none of it's cool
oh it isn't nope none of it today my
view today is i'm so anti-war really yup
but at the time you had a different
perception you had to yeah had to
but today it's all
tell me one war we've been in since
world war ii
that accomplished something
yeah tell me one
ain't any
tell me one that accomplished something
yeah none
yeah
why were they fought i don't know
i'll finish with this
my father had my mother and father are
both world war ii veterans yeah my mom
was a nurse in north africa that
predated normandy wow not many can say
their mom
and my mom was actually injured and sent
back home
in north africa as a nurse
and my dad was under patton had six
bronze battle stars north africa
normandy battle of the bulge ramagan
bridge anzio and berlin and lived
jeevers jesus right those are my parents
now you kind of understand but they
weren't warmongers there were nothing
like that but now you kind of understand
why i went into service yeah everyone in
my family went into service it was kind
of just what you did
and my parents never pushed us in fact
my dad i came home from high school
and my dad was home
world war ii vets six bronze battle
stars
and i come home and told my dad dad
we got a fight in vietnam
my dad goes why why do you think that
i said we have to stop the domino effect
of communism if we don't stop him there
if the communism is going to go all over
the world that's what i and yeah that's
what they thought
everywhere
you know my dad did he looked at me and
he said
is that what they're teaching you in
school
i said yeah
my dad looked at me and said that's the
biggest bunch of i've ever
heard wow now imagine what i went
through right there
my father's telling me my teachers are
bullshitting me
i respected my teachers they did
and here's my dad
telling me they're giving me a line of
my dad looked at me and said
we're not there to stop communism
he said we're there because somebody's
making big money
well when i i was fortunate to come home
and i was fortunate that my second
deployment they had pulled us out
you know i was at the very tail end
uh february 71 until november 71.
and uh i was able to come home to my dad
and say guess what dad you were right
and my dad looked at me and said oh i
always knew i was right i said sometimes
you just have to learn things the hard
way he said i tried to i did what i felt
i had to do to tell you the truth the
rest was up to you wow
but i mean my dad was against the
vietnam war before the hippies damn
and here's a six
so you'll find that many veterans like
myself are the most anti-war people wow
because they know it doesn't accomplish
nothing and my dad fought in the popular
war jesus the one that was the great war
yeah you know the one that stopped
hitler
yeah i might add too
anyone that studies hitler in 30s
germany
take a look at donald trump
yeah
same playbook
same playbook as hitler's germany
and he's doing it right now yeah and
this country's so stupid
they're falling for it
the guy's a con man
and a good one because he's got a lot of
smart people that have bought drank the
kool-aid for lack of better these jim
jones
you know they're all do you feel like
all the uh so many politicians are con
men though huh he's not a politician
right that's a good point
and
also too you know how the rock has said
he might run and all this
what these what people need to
understand is this
yes jesse ventura won
but they need to understand jesse
ventura has done 14 years of public
service right
donald trump had done none yeah the rock
to my knowledge i love the rock but he's
done none right
i was in the military six years so i
understand that part
right right that's public service right
you were mayor i was a mayor of the
sixth largest city for four years and i
was a governor for four years so i've
every branch of government
so i have experience in the public
sector yeah these guys don't and here's
the big difference and i'll end with
this
the difference is this
the private sector is for-profit
the public sector is to provide services
there's a big difference
these guys that come from the private
sector bring only expertise at making
profit
they don't bring the expertise at
providing public service yeah
government is public service it's to
provide for the masses yeah the good of
the
many
not the good of the few and not the good
of the elite
or the rich it's to the masses
these guys have no donald trump had no
experience
especially not i don't think of helping
anyone but himself i would agree with
that you know and that's how come he
came in and governed the same way yeah
and why people think he's the messiah
i've had people you know i'm agnostic
atheist right i've had people tell me
donald trump is a good christian yeah
you know what i responded with well if
he's a good christian i'm glad i'm not
you know if that's what a good christian
is
you don't want any i don't want
no party no no part of it because he'd
sell his soul to rock and roll baby
he'll sell out the he'll sell out look
what look at what he's done to all the
people around him
if you don't count out to him he sells
y'all down the river man yeah yeah i
think it's so many of those guys it's
the dark arts man i just wonder how do
we get out of the system how do we break
this this don't vote for democrats and
republicans agree it's it's as simple as
the nose on your face yeah but it's as
difficult as climbing mount everest yeah
yeah you know and especially let me
throw this out especially
here's one that goes beyond my belief
when you have a state like like i said
the taliban's in texas now
i call texas the home of the talent the
united states taliban
because
do you know right now it's easier to buy
a gun in texas than vote
man now
isn't there something inherently wrong
with that
yeah you can buy a gun
in texas easier than you can vote
jeepers
nobody's gonna idea for the gun
you can walk in anywhere in texas and
buy a gun
but if you got a vote yeah oh you got to
register jump through hoops they've
closed voting places you maybe have to
drive 30 miles
can't mail nothing in anymore
you know none of that we will and you
know there's no voter fraud
i can tell you i knew that when i got
into office in minnesota we did a huge
study and it came back
nothing significant yeah and all the
things they've caught now the only votes
they've caught have been votes for trump
that were illegal yeah
you know
who
here's the part that makes me laugh
who do they think is out organizing
voter fraud
and for what purpose
you got local people that volunteer
their good time
to be independent and count these votes
like great american citizens and then
you got the trumpies telling them
they're all a bunch of crooks yeah
how dare these trumpies say that well i
think they have no proof i think there's
none i think there's no way to determine
if those people counting the votes what
their
allegiances are both are there right
both are represented well if they're not
behind closed doors yeah then that's
totally that makes sense and they had
that phony recount in arizona yeah biden
won
even when they hired their hired guns to
come in and hopefully switch it over so
they'd have an argument yeah none of
that amounted to anything
well 60 court cases all thrown out yeah
rudy giuliani getting disbarred in some
states now because he brought these
lawsuits or
brought things to court with no evidence
yeah which they do have rules you know
yeah as a lawyer
you can't just bring frivolous things
forward you gotta have evidence they had
no evidence of nothing yeah and yet
people have bought into it and said it
happened
that is interesting i don't know it's
funny to know how how involved people
are where people what people are
trusting have any of you ever met anyone
that committed voter fraud
you know all your years on the planet
ever talked to anyone about doing it
no
it's not almost every christian we've
got four people in the room and it's
only come to light in the last year or
two
voter fraud that's a good point nobody
cared you know there's no nobody any
other election and and trump gave us a
preview because remember all leading up
to the election he was he was setting
himself up if he lost
oh if i lose it's because it's rigged
yeah remember he started that early on
out i'll tell you the person that knows
him
forward and backwards is that niece of
his have you seen her oh i see a real
diamond
no she oh no he's nice
she's a trump
she she's a psychologist
legit oh she went to college
she gets on tv and dissects his brain
everything she said about him is exactly
what happens interesting she said he
will never admit losing the election
no matter what yeah that's a lot of his
thing is no admission never will admit
it of uh defeat and then he's got all
these people out there that
are buying the kool-aid like this guy's
a hero
i don't know i think different people
like him for different reasons this guy
ran from the draft yeah he bought his
now i look up to muhammad ali
and muhammad ali ran from the draft you
know what the difference is though
you know what the difference is
ali was willing to go to jail for his
beliefs
trump wasn't trump bought his way out
trump faced no charges yeah
trump buck you know that's rich people
rigged the system that's rich people but
see see ali
and alida had it made they already told
him you're gonna do nothing but what joe
lewis did you'll go down you'll do
exhibitions
ali wasn't going to get he knew they
were going to use him to get black kids
to volunteer to send to vietnam he was
going to have none of it
muhammad was not going to be the
catalyst that sent his
black kids you know people have asked me
if i've ever used the n-word yeah and i
have to admit i have
yeah i used it no i used it when i quote
ali oh wow i quote muhammad ali and he
used it so if he can use it i can quote
him yeah yeah
and he said it about the viet cong
remember he said no viet cong never
called me
the n-word oh wow
no no i remember when muhammad said that
to the press ain't no vietcong what do i
want to fight these people for ain't no
vietcong ever called me
the answer the n-word
you know
and so muhammad wouldn't get sucked in
to bring in all the other blacks so they
could kill them in vietnam and send them
because blacks were very much just
disproportionately represented in
vietnam really they didn't have a lot of
them they what was our black population
then maybe 10 11
was it even that high and what percent
were in vietnam way more really sure
yeah we're still just the people that
serve like that are the poor people oh
yeah well it's a lot of latina it's a
lot of mexican and black it's a lot of
poor white
um in my neighborhood in south
minneapolis
i grew up in south minneapolis by the
lake street bridge
where what's his name died
is my old neighborhood is all through
there yeah george floyd yeah well if you
grew up there you maybe had to go to
work right well then you went to vietnam
i have all sorts of friends that got
drafted yeah but again if you lived out
at lake minnetonka or edina you didn't
see vietnam you went to college you got
deferments yeah see it was so
unfair it's always been like that though
it's always the poorest people are
always the ones you know what they're
going to do if they bring it back going
to have to draft women wow
some of these need to go out oh
they'll have to yeah how could they not
look it's time i want to see i'm going
to i don't want to see no draft at all i
worked against the draft i came back and
used to
used to march against the draft
absolutely wow
why should us do why should the rich get
out of it oh i don't think the rich
should get out of it but i think you got
to find a way to get everybody to be
draft and make it fair that's why a lot
of these things it's like if it started
happening to the rich people things why
do you need if we weren't involved in
all these wars we wouldn't need all
these people yeah and besides you kill
people with pushing a button more than
you do with
boots on the ground these days the
actual people aren't having a chance in
their own life even almost in their own
safety out there the whole war thing is
is sad because we spend all our money in
preparation for war
i mean everyone's bitching about biden's
3.5 trillion dollar being too much it's
too much to spend that on us
they have no problem spending that in
afghanistan right had no problem
spending it in iraq but yet here they're
going to spend it on people in the
united states and there's an outrage
yeah it's too much
too much money for us yeah it's our
money but it's too much for us
oh god don't give it to us don't help
out americans
certainly we could ship it off to a war
and build a nation somewhere
you know we could spend trillions like
we did in afghanistan and iraq and what
do we have to show for it zilch not a
ton you know but oh god no don't that's
way bigger to price tag us republicans
aren't going to stand for that that's a
good point man you know you're spending
the money on us yeah on people of
america
jobs programs and and and and you know
uh uh
leave so women can work and think you
know for kids and babies and all oh god
we don't want to spend money on that
when we can spend money on a new
aircraft carrier yeah that's crazy huh
you know jesus come on it's yeah that is
i hope everyone's getting my sarcasm i
hope i'm being over the top it's a lot
of a dirty phone good good good because
you never know today somebody's going oh
you should heard what jesse said well
them man people look i think you
speak loud and clear and i think it's
obvious what you say and uh just you
have quite a body of work and i just
appreciate you being here and spending
time today there was something you're a
comedian i am man i am uh finish me with
a freaking joke sometimes
i'm gonna put you on the hot spot give
me a freaking joke comedian
uh
let me think of something good man all
right let's let's you let's happen at
golf years ago okay i was playing with
the and a guy from wisconsin told it to
me uh-huh
did you hear about when jeffrey dahmer
had his mom over for dinner
you know jeffrey dahmer oh yeah yeah the
dangerous man yeah you heard about when
he had his mom over for dinner uh-uh
yeah well he had his mom over for dinner
and his mom said jeffrey you know i just
don't care for these friends of yours
and jeffrey said that's okay mom try the
vegetables
[Laughter]
now to ref
to remind you dahmer's the guy that was
the cannibal oh yeah i know i know i
almost ate a freaking vietnamese guy one
time in a damn best buy
i thought i heard that joke playing golf
i thought it was kind of funny you know
look i think it's good man you got to
remember the cheese heads over there
they birth a lot of these you know about
ed gean right oh yeah yeah oh yeah he's
a cheese head right across the room he's
a packers fan
sure yeah wow i don't know if he was a
packers fan but he's a cheese head oh
yeah yeah he was that's somebody from
worcester he's from illinois where he
was from
yes i thought he's from illinois well no
he's wisconsin about
800 miles over the border over there a
lot of creeps out there
yeah that's what they did psycho did you
know lee harvey oswald went to school in
my hometown did he yeah in louisiana
pretty cool man yeah um
you know who you would love to talk to
you man is robert kennedy uh bob jr i've
talked to him you have yeah he's a
really smart guy man both you guys just
have so much information i've taken his
sun diving wow that's cool oh his sons
are awesome aren't they good kids his
son
was down in cabo
and we have a mutual friend dick russell
who i've done books with
and uh and so
robert's son wanted to go diving with an
authentic frog band wow so i went over
there and joined him and
and i took robert's son diving yeah so
he could dive with an authentic real
frog man that's cool pretty excited over
that and it was i enjoyed it you know
kind of granting the kids wish you know
yeah you know we'll tell his friends
yeah i've dove with a real frog man yeah
you know so uh no he's he's the special
guest i've ever been 212 feet damn under
the water what was down there nothing
yeah blackard and hell can't see a thing
like yeah you see your hand in front of
your face do you get scared or no yeah
it's a bounce dive where you go down
we did off point loma it's a great story
uh bounce dive probably 10 or 12 pairs
of guys what you do is you're going down
212 feet you're staying there for a
minimum time so you don't have to
decompress
so your bottom's about 30 seconds okay
then you got to start coming up but you
come up only where's your slowest
bubbles are you on a rope yeah okay
the thing down you get down there and
you'll see how deep you they dropped it
down 212 feet
so we went down 212 feet and the good
part was off point loma
we all got done about 10 swim pairs we
were pulling the rubber raft boat into
the pl boat and one of my teammates go
is on the fan tail the back he goes hey
guys check it out and he points over
here
here come a freaking great white yeah
swimming right on the surface dorsal fin
about a foot and a half out of the water
cruised right by us as big as jaws
and we're all sitting in the pl boat
watching this big boy go by
we had detracted his attention
apparently us going up and down the
pairs
he came over to see what what's this
damn and we had just all happened to
getting out of the water when he went
cruising by see i was happy that i was
in the seals and was a frog man
jaws didn't come out till 75. oh i was
discharged out of the navy by then
because if they'd had jaws yeah i'm sure
they would have showed it to us one
night in training yeah we would have had
to sat and watched jaws and then go on a
swim oh that would have been no i mean
the instructors would do that just to
get guys to quit yeah okay you just
watched jaws now we're going on a
two-mile ocean swim i'd quit
i'd equip man
i had to do five miles really yup
straight or is it yeah they just take
you five miles from the beach in san
diego and they dump you off they're out
there with a pl they got an m16
in case anything comes around
you know there's always a guy with an
m16
and they you're you're out so far
with in the swells you can't even see
the skyscrapers of san diego wow at
water level
and they just point and say that way and
you start swimming and five miles takes
you good part of the day damn
you know you spend i was a good swimmer
so i got in early it is enjoyable do you
kick your legs when you swim you just
use your arms you got fins on damn right
yeah yeah cripe you don't want to not
use your fins yeah i messed up you do it
you got to qualify for them though you
got to swim a swim under a certain time
then you get your fins oh damn and then
from that point on you can do all your
swims with fins
and you hell you're in the ocean you
want fins oh yeah you're not in a pool
you know i did my share of swimming on
the line yeah you know competitive
swimming
my claim to fame i actually swam in the
same pool with mark spitz once oh damn
you know didn't compete against him i
just was in the same pool could you have
been a competitive swimmer not i was
just not at his level yeah
he's the seven
olympic gold medals yeah
when phelps broke his record it was
remarkable i didn't think anyone ever
would
but spitz's record was still better than
phelps's eight you know why
spitz's seven is better than phelps's
eight in my opinion because it was in
more categories
[Music]
one reason um spitzer's seven gold
medals were also seven world records
phelps's eight gold medals were eight
gold medals but not every swim was a
world record
mark spitz is
golds were also seven world records i
take i like that you know seven gold
medals seven world records
i can barely swim and uh oh i
could i swam i
spent more time in a pool than i did
on land i would ride on your back i bet
i would probably ride on your back
that's why i don't swim today yeah i
don't even i love a place on the ocean i
don't even go out in it damn there's
what's out there you've seen it all
you've been through all what do i want
to go out there for
you got a big body of work jesse ventura
you got a big body of work you haven't
given me a joke yet i can't leave i gave
you a joke now i i i gave you the dahmer
joke you're right you're a comedian find
me a freaking joke all right i got this
joke then this is one
uh
what do you call a fish with no eyes
a fish with no uh what do you call a
fish with no eyes
and it's got to be so okay what what's
in the water that's blind
i don't know what
a what
my niece told me that one thank god it
was your niece
okay i'll i'll give it a pass now
because your niece told you that one i
wanted something from your comedy roots
oh here's what i got from your little
niece who comes up with a funny
okay tell you that's right
how old was she uh i think she's nine
yeah well that's that uh that fits about
a nine yeah that's good here all right
nine year old very good okay here's one
give me one from your routine okay my
cousin just got busted for uh
sucking really small dicks
that's just a joke so
so either way you lose here i mean
they're all bad ones where are you
playing all that so i know where i'm not
going
jesse you better get something to make
me laugh
you know what i got a special coming up
now you do stand up yeah you know i've
been told that i could do that really
yeah because i can hold i can oh i could
see you holding a room yeah i could see
you doing tours like jocko willing does
he does a lot of speaking and tours well
and what i do i don't really do stand-up
comedy but i do a lot of make people
laugh yeah
with the stupidity of things i tell them
i'd like to uh oh i think the points you
would make and bring in insight into
people i think would be
a lot of people would be laughing at
themselves because
like i said earlier the thrill for me
was being able to go to harvard and i
i'll tell you this too
maybe they've been broken now but i had
the largest classes in harvard history
damn
they had to move me into the commons
because my classes were open to
everybody
and so oh yeah they had to move me in
the commons because it was
the place would just fill up oh dude
you're like you remind me of like
christopher lloyd if he had big
balls you know yeah well and it was fun
just it was fun for me
to be able to go there and influence
kids who i know and are going to end up
probably being important right you know
because of where they go to school and
and everything like that
and that's like when muhammad ali went
and spoke at a harvard graduation wow
you know and i need to go back and
listen to some of that stuff and you
know muhammad when he spoke at the
harvard graduation he set the world's
record for the shortest poem damn
he did what it was you remember yeah
he uh he was speaking at the graduates
of harvard i heard the story told
and somebody in the crowd yelled out
give us a poem
and ali looked at the crowd and it was
the shortest
it should be the shortest in history
he went me
we
it's not that's all right and that's the
shortest poll
me we
and ali did that off his top of his head
oh that's interesting the guy who talked
about it was sod plimpton
i think it was i heard george plimpton
another one of them famous writers
and they said they looked it up and they
said that qualifiers because the one
before had three syllables
ali's had two
and then the one that was listed as the
record had three syllables he was a real
master you know i was lucky i got to
spend a day with him really oh yeah
what y'all do y'all go to dinner no
sat in his house
in springs i didn't want to go to no
freaking dinner yeah i wanted to i was
in his house all day
with just
his people and me and my people
and uh
he well because the story is when i won
the governor
um i got up and i talked that night
about
that i was a young kid when muhammad ali
then cassius clay beat sonny liston for
the world title
i said nobody believed that cassius
would win now ali
and i said that night he said he shocked
the world well i said tonight we shocked
the world gang
don't end there
i'm in the governor-elect
i mean the bowels of the capital haven't
taken over yet and
a business friend of mine harvey mckay
shows up on my schedule for 10 minutes
and harvey walks this aubrey what are
you doing here he said i brought you
something and you had a big box
better open it i opened the box up
on the inside was a pair of everlast
boxing gloves oh wow
i hate this part because
what makes you sad well he's my hero oh
yeah
the boxing gloves
said to governor ventura
you shocked the world muhammad ali
he was watching ah that night
sorry
he was watching that night
and he took the time
and that's what set up for me to come
visit him wow and when i went to visit
him he was of course stricken with the
parkinson's
but his wife lonnie said to me she said
you know muhammad wouldn't take his
medicine last night
and i said why she said because it
it slows him down and he didn't want to
be slow he was so excited you were
coming today
and i thought muhammad ali is excited
that i'm coming
to see him
give me a break
you know
what what what made you so happy that he
was proud of you
because he's my hero yeah
he's he's a guy who
if you read his biography he developed
his whole style from pro wrestling oh
wow
and uh
he uh
battled the system
he was a man who stood up for what he
believed in and was willing to pay the
price for it and i don't think there's a
better hero you can have
in the world
and so he's my hero he always was he
always will be
and i think it kind of shocked muhammad
because uh
do you want to hear what i did for him
that day yeah i would like to hear that
and this will be the ending i don't know
if your tape's still running we might be
out of tape that's okay here's what i i
looked at him and i said
i am the greatest by cassius clay
this is the legend of cassius clay the
most beautiful fighter in the world
today he talks a great deal and brags in
deity of a muscular punch that's
incredibly speedy the fistic world was
dull and weary with a champ like list
and things had to be dreary then someone
with color someone would dash brought
fight fans are running with cash this
brass young boxer is something to see
and the heavyweight championship is his
destiny this kid fights great he's got
speed and endurance but if you sign to
fight him increase your insurance
this kid's got a left this kid's got a
right if he hits you once you're asleep
for the night and as you lie on the
floor while the ref counts ten you pray
that you won't have to fight me again
for i am the man this story's about i'll
be champ of the world there isn't a
doubt here i predict mr liston's
dismemberment i'll hit him so hard he'll
wonder where october and november went
here i predict and i know the score
i'll be champ of the world in 64.
no
that's off memory yeah
that's your hair tell me he would he he
didn't
and when i did that for him
he had tears in his eyes because i think
he thought what the hell would a little
white boy in south minneapolis
and you know where that's from
he did an album
way back called i am the greatest
disc
where he's standing there with his foot
up and holding a fist i am the greatest
by cassius clay i used to listen to that
album
day in and day out wow as a young
10 11 year old kid
who wanted to be a fighter and ended up
a wrestler yeah
he ended up pretty close though well
muhammad learned from uh wrestling no
it's interesting yeah no he said he went
to an interview once and it was him and
gorgeous george
and he sat and lis and he was early in
his career and he heard gorgeous george
bragging away and doing what wrestlers
do
well muhammad said that night i was
boxing in front of 20 people he said
gorgeous george was wrestling in front
of 5 000. wow
light went off muhammad said you got to
sell yourself here
you got to do what these wrestlers do
start and that's when he started naming
the round yeah they all must fall in the
round i call they almost lose in the
round i choose
you know and he started predicting his
knockouts and then he did it speaking
things into existence too it's kind of
wild that's what really got him going
they then did it yeah you know but no
ali
ali was bigger than life really
for what he stood for and
you know this kid from louisville who
rose up and
learned and
wouldn't be manipulated
and uh
and he he he stood for what he believed
and he wouldn't compromise
and i'd like to believe that everything
i do is very much in
that aspect for me too and then if
whatever i do i'd make him proud
you know
and
we ran into each other later out in l.a
i saw lonnie at the hotel in beverly
hills i looked and said lonnie what are
you doing here i thought jesse did a i
said is muhammad here she goes oh yeah
he's up she told me to force it okay
should go up he'd love to see you
so i ran to the other it's that hotel
that's on both sides of the street i ran
to the other one got in the elevator
went up there she told me the door rang
the doorbell up there and i'll never
forget this young black kid
opened the door
he saw it was me
and his jaw dropped and he was frozen
and i looked at the black kid and i
thought
and he could i thought you're frozen
looking at me and you're in a room with
muhammad ali
something wrong with this picture
are you kidding me you know this kid was
all
jesse ventura
so i came in and mohamed and i hugged
and talked and
had a good little thing there and he was
the car was coming for him he was doing
something or other and
you know and i was out there doing
business or whatever and
then later you know of course he died
and all of that but he'll live forever
yeah you know i think is you'll live as
long as i'm around because he's loving
the story i mean he lives through
stories lived through lore even my dad
and my dad knew a lot about boxing he
fought a little himself and all that the
world war ii vet
my dad gave in to me in the end
you know what he said
he said that clay kid he said he's the
best ever wow and i said why is that dad
why'd you say that my dad died in 91.
and i said dad how come now you say that
muhammad's the best ever
he said i'll tell you why he said speed
he said no heavyweight
has ever had the speed that guy had with
his legs and his hands
he said he'd have beat them all
and my dad grew up with dempsey grew up
with all that
but he said alita beat them all he said
there was no way they could have
contended with his speed
and he proved it well you'd prove the
opposite to george foreman yeah he got
george with rope-a-dope yeah yeah yeah
oh he's remarkable to watch man you know
changed his whole style and got
george to punch himself out he's one of
a kind big george did
and george ended up being a hell of a
guy after that george foreman's you know
he went into depression i heard for two
years but when he came out of it george
foreman is one of the most likable guys
in the world now amen you know and and
today he just says i just thank goodness
i thought i'll eat wow
he made me
took me to elements i'd never got
well you doing that for us jesse we
thank you so much for your time jesse
the body ventura thank you so much for
being here today man thank you have a
good day